bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi de finance alors samedi
après-midi le Sénat a réduit les crédits
de l'Ame l'aide médicale d'État il les a
réduit à son niveau de 2008 soit
475 millions d'euros le gouvernement
voulait lui augmenter c'est crédit à 760
millions pour le sénateur UMP Francis de
lâre il faut rénover profondément ce
dispositif qui progresse à un rythme
insoutenable
50 % entre 2008 et 2013 a déclaré le
sénateur UMP alors l'ame c'est le
principal dispositif d'accès aux soins
des personnes étrangères en situation
irrégulière et pour la gauche ce débat
sur l'aide médicale d'État est aussi
récurrent que mal voilà je vous propose
donc tout de suite d'écouter les débats
en séance Monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers
collègues la mission santé est un budget
relativement modeste 1,2
milliards car naturellement l'essentiel
des dépenses de santé figure dans le
budget de la Sécurité
sociale et 1,2 milliard par rapport au
au 200 milliards de l'assurance maladie
ça marque un peu la différence en
réalité nous avons deux
volets sur cette mission d'abord nous
avons les agences sanitaires et la
politique de prévention des agences
régional de santé à travers le programme
204 prévention sécurité sanitaire et
offre de soins et ensuite nous avons
l'aide médicale d'État laame et
l'indemnisation des victimes de la
miante pour une somme assez et modeste
de l'ordre de 10
millions alors si l'on neutralise les
mesures affectant le périmètre de
l'émission en 2015 notamment les
transferts vers Laurance maladie les
crédits augmentent d'environ 3 % par
rapport à
2014 en août le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
prévoit une augmentation d'environ 2 %
des crédits de la mission sur la période
2015-2017 alors même que l'État s'impose
une l'évolution zéro valeur cette
progression globale masque une évolution
très contrastée des deux programmes de
la mission le projet de loi de finance
pour 2015 prvoir une baisse de 4,4 % des
subventions pour charge de service
public versés aux opérateurs sanitaires
tandis que les crédits destinés à laame
l'aide médicale d'État augmentent de 12
% par rapport à
2014 avec
678 678 million d'euros de crédit ouvert
pour l'année 2015 l'ame constitue donc
la principale dépense de la mission et
c'est l'assurance maladie qui gère ces
sommes pour le compte de
l'État alors si on regarde les dépenses
des dernières années on s'aperçoit que
celle-ci augmente une façon très
importante notamment pour laame d de
droit commun qui constitue le dispositif
central financé par l'État pour soigner
les les
étrangers installés sur notre territoire
en situation
irrégulière depuis 2002 ces dépenses ont
augmenté pour laame de droit commun de
90 % et de 50 % depuis 2008 se
rapprochant ainsi chaque année en suce
de ce qui est assuré directement par
l'assurance maladie du milliard d'euros
ceci est d'autant plus vrai si l'on
tient compte des dépenses prises en
charge justement par laassurance maladie
pour au titre des soins urgents nous
avons donc une surexécution massive qui
devient récurrent depuis quelques années
même l'autorisation voté en 2013 a été
dépassé de 26 %. et le projet de loi de
finance rectificative pour 2014 prévoit
l'ouverture de 155 millions d'euros
supplémentaires ce qui portera le
montant des crédits alloués à la me
environ 760 millions d'euros le 28
octobre j'ai adressé un courrier à
Madame la Ministre des Affaires sociales
de la santé et des droits des femmes
afin de l'alerter sur la sincérité même
des budgétisations et de la
budgétisation pour 2015 et je me suis
permis de l'interroger sur les mesures
qui étaient envisagées pour contenir les
dépenses à ce jour je n'ai pas reçu de
de réponse ni même aucune indication ni
même le moindre
signe la question de l'accès aux soins
des étrangers en situation régulière est
complexe elle est aussi la conséquence
de notre absence de politique migratoire
elle mérite certainement qu'un travail
approfondi soit conduit afin
d'identifier les pistes permettant
d'féchir son coût tout en garantissant
une prise en charge des urgences et de
mesures sanitaires collectives
éventuelles dans l'immédiat la
commission des finances vous propose
d'adopter un amendement visant réuire
les crédits allués à la me de droit
commun de 156 millions d'euros ce qui
les ramènerait à leur niveau constaté en
2008 sur environ 475 millions d'euros il
nous semble que c'est une option
préférable près beaucoup de
démar préférable au rejet des crédits de
la mission qui pourrait être interprété
comme un rejet global de la me or
qu'elle est utile et indispensable pour
une partie de ses responsabilités de ces
activités un accès au soins urgents doit
être maintenu par les étrangers en
grande vulnérabilité qui se trouve sur
le sol français certes en situation
régulière mais dont l'urgence de soin
est
patente mais non comme l'accès normal à
un guichet a un droit par cet amendement
la commission des finances affirme sa
volonté d'inciter à lainovation en
profondeur de l'Ame afin de ramener
cette dépense à un niveau soutenable
comme on fait l'ensemble des pays
européens qui nous entourent en
redéfinissant des critères
d'accessibilité et des
contrôles enfin l'article 59 secs
traduit introduit par l'Assemblée
nationale en première lecture ne pose
aucune difficulté puisqu'il vise à
réduire le délai de facturation des
séjours hospitaliers des patients
bénéficiaire de la me de 2 ans à 1 an
les délaiis de demande de paiement sont
a si aligné sur ceux de droit commun ce
qui constitue une mesure de gestion vous
avez donc naturellement compris qu'il
s'agit d'un amendement fort d'appel qui
pour nous inciter tous ici à la
réflexion afin de redéfinir des
critères pour un sujet qui nous savons
tous dans l'opinion publique est un
sujet récurrent de discussion à travers
bien souvent un manque d'information
donc nous proposerons nous mettrons en
place un groupe de travail pour y
travailler sérieusement et de faire pour
l'exercice budgétaire prochain et si
Madame le
Ministre voulez bien bien nous y aider
ça serait très volontier voilà merci mon
cher collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Ren Paul savar rapporteur pour avis de
la commission des affaires
sociales
bien madame la ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues la
commission des affaires sociales a donné
un avis défavorable autant annoncer la
couleur tout de suite défavorable aux
orientation budgétaire définie par le
gouvernement pour cette mission santé
les contraintes croissantes qui pèsent
sur les agences sanitaires à un moment
où celles-ci doivent assurer les
missions toujours plus denses et la
progression non maîtrisée des crédits
laame lui paraisse en effet rappeler une
position plus que réservée grandtin
s'agissant du programme 204 les
opérateurs sanitaire de l'État ils sont
invités à approfondir les efforts
d'efficience de et de productivité
auquels ils s'astraignent depuis
maintenant plusieurs exercices le PLF
pour 2015 propose de diminuer le montant
total des entions qui leur sont alloué
de 4,4 % et de réduire leur plafond
d'autorisation d'emploi d'environ 2 %.
la Commission considère comme tout à
fait légitime que les agences sanitaires
prenent leur part dans la mesure de
redressement des finances publiques la
poursuite de la démarche de
rationalisation suscite cependant
aujourd'hui des inquiétudes d'autant
plus forte qu'elle s'ajoute à
l'attribution de missions nouvelles aux
incertitudes liées au projet de loi
relatif à la santé dont nous débattrons
prochainement je ne prendrai qu'un seul
exemple l'Agence nationale de sécurité
d'une médicaments la NSN malgré une
subvention en baisse de plus de 3 % une
diminution de 20 équivalent temps plein
par rapport à 2014 l'agence devra non
seulement organiser la montée en
puissance de son département de
pharmacoépidémiologie mais également
s'assurer de la mise en œuvre du nouveau
règlement européen relatif aux essais
cliniques des médicaments elle devra en
outre garantir l'application des mesures
de la prochaine loi de santé concernant
notamment la sécurisation de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement en médicaments ou
encore la création d'un accès ouvert aux
données de santé toutes les agence du
programme 204 ont souligné la nécessité
de garder une taille critique suffisante
pour maintenir une expertise de qualité
de ce point de vue notre assemblée devra
être attentif à l'article 42 du projet
de loi relatif à la santé
qui entend habiliter le gouvernement à
agir par ordonnance pour réformer le
système d'agence sanitaire l'étude
d'impact reste en en effet relativement
sibiline sur la façon dont sont envisagé
l'articulation des missions des
différents opérateurs et les moyens qui
leur seront
attribués peut-être pourrez-vous d'ors
et déjà madame la ministre nous donner
quelques éclairages par rapport à cela
en ce qui concerne maintenant le
programme 183 la commission des affaires
sociales révèle également que les
dépenses ilme se caractérisent par une
augmentation très soutenu leur rythme
d'augmentation plus de 12 % et bien
supérieur à celui des dépenses
d'assurance maladie mais elles souffrent
surtout d'une absence totale de
fiabilité des prévisions budgétaires
pour 2015 les crédits ouverts au titre
de l'ame de droit commun s'élèverait à
633 millions d'euros alors que la
dépense tendantielle est de 7 117
millions d'euros comme chaque année le
gouvernement est ainsi conduit à ouvrir
des crédits supplémentaires dans le
collectif budgétaire de fin d'année
parallèlement les restes à charge de
l'État vis-à-vis de l'assurance maladie
se maintiennent puisque la dette
s'élèverit pour 2013 à près de 52
millions d'euros de l'État vers
l'assurance maladie la Cour des comptes
d'ailleurs a considéré que cette
situation faisait piser un risque
d'insoutenabilité sur le programme 180
23 et dans ces conditions la commission
des affaires sociales considère que des
mesures complémentaires aux ajustements
en cours sont nécessaires elle a adopté
sur ma proposition un amendement en
complément de celui proposé par le
sénateur deâre un amendement qui
institue pour les bénéficiaires de laame
une contribution forfaitaire annuelle
comparable à la participation plafonné
de droit commun à laquel sont soumis les
assurés lorsqu'ils recourent à des soins
médicaux soit le forfait de 50 € tout en
envoyant un signal responsable cette
mesure ne remet en cause ni la nécessité
de protéger les personnes concernées ni
la capacité à éviter que des infections
non soignées ne s'étend elle permet donc
de rester fidèle au double objectif
sanitaire du dispositif donc madame la
ministre pour conclure avis défavorable
parce qu'il y a des ordonnances au
niveau de du programme 204 et avis
défavorable également sur le problème
programme 193 nous fait de
l'inoutenabilité des propositions
budgétaires pour ce programme je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur je
vous rappelle que le temps de parole
attribué à chaque groupe pour chaque
discussion comprend le temps
d'intervention générale et celui de
l'explication de vote je vous rappelle
également qu'en application des
décisions de la conférence des
présidents aucune intervention des
orateurs des groupes ne doit dépasser 10
minutes par ailleurs le gouvernement
dispose au total de 15 minutes pour
intervenir la parole est à Monsieur
Vincent deay pour le groupe udi
UC monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la Présidente de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur spécial chers
collègues je ne suis pas un spécialiste
des questions de santé toutefois en tant
que vice-président de la commission des
finances je peux certifier que la
mission santé est devenue un symbole de
tous les défauts de notre droit
budgétaire
contemporain je dirais pas comme mon
collègue qui qui vient de s'exprimer que
c'est parce qu'il y a des ordonnance que
on votera pas la mission puisque c'est
une mission santé qu'il y ait des
ordonnances dans la santé ça me pas tout
à fait naturel pour ma
part mais attention je ne remets pas en
cause le bien fondé de l'existence de
cette mission c'est sa gestion qui me
semble poser plusieurs problèmes
particuliers doté de 1illard 200
millions d'euros de crédit la volume de
la mission santé progresse de 3,3 %
cette année autant le dire tout de suite
cette mission ne participe pas du tout
de à l'effort d'économie prétendument
affiché par le
gouvernement avec 3,3 % de hausse des
crédit il n'y a pas d'économie sur la
tendance ce qu'on nous a rappelé assez
souvent il y a encore moins sur le
volume bref il n'y a pas d'économie du
tout et ça ne pose de problème
visiblement à
personne ce qui est vrai de la dépense
budgétaire les aussi de la dépense
fiscale notre rapporteur spécial notre
excellent rapporteur spécial dé nombre
d' niches fiscales associé à cette
mission seul CIN de ces niches ont été
jugé efficaces par l'Inspection générale
des finances je rappelle que le rapport
Guillaume sur l' fiscale date du mois
d'août 2011 c'était il y a plus de 3 ans
et depuis rien n'a été fait c'est tout
le problème rien n'est fait finalement
personne ne veut vraiment faire
grand-chose nous sommes sur un bateau
qui avance du fait de sa propre inertie
il n'y a plus de capitaine à la barre
pour rectifier la
trajectoire d'un côté nous avons le
programme 204 dont les crédits diminuent
de 5,8 % par rapport à cette année il y
a manifestement effort des opérateurs
sanitaires pour améliorer leur gestion
en dépit des difficultés inhérentes à
administration d'un établissement
hospitalier en revanche et c'est le
principal point d'achopement de cette
mission les crédits du programme 183 qui
finance l'aide médicale d'État explose
plus 14 % en un
an même comme cela même comme cela notre
rapporteur spécial estime que cette
enveloppe est sousbudget tant tout en
étant mal
documenté là encore le Parlement fait
face aux défauts non solutionnés par la
LOLF nous n'avons aucune prise sur les
dépenses de guichet de telle sorte que
dès que le guichet est ouvert librement
à tous la dépense
explose derrière le problème financier
de la sous budgétisation de l'Ame se
cache en réalité la question du
fonctionnement même de ce
dispositif créé en 2000 sous le
gouvernement de Lionel Jospin l'aide
médicale d'État permet aux étrangers en
situation irrégulière mais aussi aux
personnes placées en rétention
administrative ou en garde à vue lorsque
leur état de santé le justifie de
bénéficier d'un accès aux soins ce droit
d'accès est accordé également aux ayant
droit de ces personnes la France sonore
de sa propre
générosité malheureusement je suis amené
à reprendre cette phrase bien connue de
l'ancien Premier ministre Michel Rocard
la France n'a pas vocation à accueillir
toute la misère du monde mais elle doit
en prendre sa juste part alors quelle
est sa juste part l'ame était
conditionné au paiement d'un droit de
timbre de 30 € depuis l'adoption des
dispositions proposées par le
gouvernement Fillon en
2011 l'objectif était de freiner la
dynamique de la dépense tout en gardant
un accès ouvert aux soins ce droit de
timbre a été supprimé lors du PLFR de
l'été 2012 par le gouvernement de
Jean-Marc HUD quel bilan
aujourd'hui crédit de 233 millions
d'euros en 2005 l'aide médicale d'État
dépasserait aujourd'hui les 700 millions
d'euros d'après le rapport spécial de
Francis del lâre d'autres dont je suis
parle même d'un milliard
d'euros la suppression du droit de
timbre a sans doute trop largement
ouvert l'accès à un dispositif accusé de
favoriser le tourisme médical et la
fraude mais ce n'est pas la seule
explication un problème d'équité se pose
également l'ame est plus favorable que
la CMU
où est l'équité dans l'accès aux soins
entre étrangers en situation irrégulière
et personnes en situation
régulière bien évidemment nous ne
pouvons pas nous passer d'un tel
dispositif pour des raisons à la fois
sanitaires mais aussi
morales toutefois la France tarde tant à
prendre à sa charge une plus grande part
de la misère du monde que celle qui
devrait justement lui
revenir il n'y a pas de solution simple
au problème de
l'Ame couper des crédit sousbudgétisé
auraiit le mérite d'envoyer un signal
mais ne résoudra pas le problème
idem pour le Tro de timbre payer une
fois 30 € ne permet pas de financer le
dispositif et ne dis soit pas
spécialement d'y
recourir cela ne va pas empêcher de
déposer deux fois un amendement pour le
rétablir au-delà de la question
financière il nous faut lutter contre
les filières qui font la promotion du du
tourisme médical en France en
bénéficiant des failles administratives
du système de fonction de la
me pour ma part je crois que
l'instération d'un ticket modérateur
soit le paiement d'une somme réduite
mais à chaque prestation pour accéder à
un panier de soins défini li
limitativement serait une voie
intéressante à suivre toutefois n'étant
pas un spécialiste des questions de
santé j'appelle le Sénat à prendre ce
sujet à bras le corp et à créer une
mission d'information ou un groupe de
travail à ce sujet afin que nous
puissions au-delà des signaux politiques
envoyés au gouvernement trouver de
véritables solutions vous le voyez
madame la ministre avec le rapporteur
spécial qui je crois est d'accord et l'a
dit tout à l'heure sur la création de ce
groupe de travail ou cette commission
nous sommes prêts à aider le
gouvernement à prendre des décisions à
la matière ça fait depuis 2 ans lors des
débats budgétaires que nous abordons
cette question peut-être même avant mais
je n'étais pas là mais le gouvernement
s'engage à chaque fois à prendre des
dispositions pour limiter la dérive de
ce dispositif et nous ne voyons toujours
rien
venir aussi les sénateurs du groupe udi
UC ne feront pas obstacle à l'adoption
des crédits de cette mission en dépit de
tous les défauts dont est accablé à
condition que nous suivions les
positions du rapporteur spécial de la
commission des finances et que nous
interpellions donc à travers
l'amendement qui sera proposé tout à
l'heure qui est un amendement d'appel et
d'interpellation du gouvernement pour
une action et une une action énergique
pour éviter de continuer à avoir ses
crédits dérivés puisqu'on sait qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui sous sousbudgétisé je
pense qu'il faut vraiment prendre le
sujet à bras le corp et nous espérons
que ce sera le cas dans les semaines à
venir je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Yve
dodini pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
messieurs les rapporteur mes chers
collègues deux impératifs me semblent
devoir guider l'examen de la mission
budgétaire santé de ce projet de loi de
finances pour 2015 en premier lieu cette
mission nécessite pour être appréhendée
dans sa réalité un effort de recul
particulier puisquelle ne constitue
qu'une part des financements de notre
protection sociale cet effort
d'appréhension globale est d'autant plus
nécessaire que la santé ne doit plus se
décliner de manière cloisonnée par
secteur mais de manière transversale
autour des trois piliers définis par la
stratégie nationale de santé en matière
de prévention d'organisation des soins
et de démocratie sanitaire il nous faut
donc tenir compte des mesures de
restructur
et de clarification des financements
déjà engagés et de celles à venir dans
le cadre du projet de loi de santé
publique ce budget constitue dans cette
perspective une étape de transition il
s'inscrit en second lieu dans l'effort
collectif de redressement des comptes
publics et de maîtrise des dépenses ces
deux considérations préalables nous
permettent d'apprécier à sa juste valeur
le montant global des crédits de la
mission porté à 1,2 milliards en 2015
soit périmètre constant par rapport au
crédit inscrit en loi de finan initiale
pour 2014 une progress de 3 %. mais les
deux programmes concernés par ces
crédits recouvrent des réalités
différentes l'un s'inscrit dans le moyen
et le long terme l'autre répond pour
l'essentiel à un impératif immédiate de
santé publique ils ne sont donc
absolument pas
comparables le programme 204 relatif à
la prévention à la sécurité sanitaire et
à l'offre de soins connait pour
l'ensemble de ces h actions une
augmentation de crédit de 0,87 % avec
toutefois une certaine disparité en
raison des modifications de périmètres
réalisés ou à venir et l'engagement
d'une première étape de rationnalisation
pour 2015 conformément aux
recommandations de la Cour des comptes
pour exemple
la réunion des centres d'information de
dépistage et de diagnostic des
infections sexuellement transmissibles
les sidistes avec les consultations de
dépistage anonyme et gratuit du VI et
des hépatites lesdinges CDAG permet leur
intégration dans les structures
financées par l'assurance méadie et la
création d'un service unique cette
mesure figuré à l'article 33 du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale et nous la av on largement
approuvé de même qu'elle a trouvé
l'accord des
associations le gouvernement a également
entendu marquer prioritairement son
soutien à la politique de prévention qui
se traduit par une dotation aux projets
régionaux de santé dans le cadre du fond
d'intervention régionale donc le F par
une dotation de plus de 130 millions
auquel s'ajoute 247 millions d'euros de
l'assurance maladie par ailleurs
la nouvelle convention d'objectif et de
gestion de la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie travailleurs
salariés assure au fond de prévention
une progression de 7,3 % des crédits
entre 2013 et 2017 soit
455,4 millions le réseau d'opérateurs
sanitaires en partie financé sur le
programme 204 dont la réorganisation est
nécessaire comme le relève à juste titre
le rapporteur pour avis de notre
commission des affaires sociales fait
l'objet d'une restructuration et
participe à la maîtrise des coûts
l'article 42 du projet de loi de santé
outre des mesures de simplification de
certaines procédures prévoit à cet égard
la création d'un nouvel établissement
public l'Institut national de prévention
de veille et d'intervention publique qui
fusionnera l'INPES l'inves et
l'prus la voie de l'ordonnance saosel
nous aurons l'occasion d'en débattre
globalement les charges de services
publics pour les agences se réduisent de
plus de 4 % en 2015 notamment grâce à
des efforts de gestion qui ont permis à
l' prus des économies sur le programme
de renouvellement des produits et le
dispositif de stockage ainsi que sur ses
dépenses de fonctionnement l'action
numéro 19 relative à l'offre de soins
connaît également un changement de
périmètre deux opérateurs de l'État le
Centre national de gestion des
praticiens hospitaliers de personnel de
direction de la fonction publique
hospitalière il faut du souffle CNG et
l'agence technique de l'information sur
l'hospitalisation la TIH pour partie
financé par l'action modernisation de
l'offre de soins sur la part de
subvention pour charge de service public
le seront par l'assurance maladie à
partir de 2015 de même qui est transféré
de la part des dépenses intervention à
l'assurance maladie le financement de la
formation médicale initiale les autres
dépenses d'intervention de l'offre de
soins reste stable pour les subventions
allouées au Jip àip santé et augmente de
près de 2,5 millions d'euros pour
l'agence de santé de Wallis et
Futuna nous ne pouvons donc nous en
tenir à la seule lecture comparée du
montant global de subvention par action
sans décomposer les crédits et examiner
les raisons de certains écarts j'en
viens au second programme de la mission
dédié à l'accès aux soins des personnes
les plus défavorisées il fixe pour 2015
une dotation de 632,6 millions pour
l'aide médicale d'État dite de droit
commun de 40 millions pour l'ame d soins
urgent et de 4,9 millions pour l'ame
humanitaire accordé sur décision
individuelles sont également couvertes
les évacuations sanitaires de personnes
étrangères résidantes à Mayotte vers
d'autres hôpitaux les frais
pharmaceutiques et les soins infirmiers
de personnes gardées à vue une ouverture
de 155,1 millions complémentaire est
également prévu en loi de finance
rectificative pour 2014 mais la dette de
l'État envers l'assurance maladie n'est
pas totalement couverte le gouvernement
a par ailleurs rétabli ce qui est une
excellente décision sa participation au
Fonds d'indemnisation des victimes de la
miante à hauteur de 10 millions d'euros
chers collègues nous allons dans
quelques instants sur l'amendement 21
adopté par la nouvelle majorité de la
commission des affaires sociales rouvrir
un débat récurrent et un débat je
voudrais le dire nécessairement
malsin parce que quelle que soit
l'intention des signataires de cette
proposition qui a pour objet de
restreindre l'accès au soins pour les
personnes les plus défavorisées quitte à
mettre d'ailleurs population en danger
quitte à ce que ce retard ou renoncement
à ce soigner coûte au final bien plus
cher pour la collectivité quelle que
soit cette intention elle ne peut-être
dissocié de la surenchère médiatique à
laquelle ce livre tout aujourd'hui rere
certains candidats à la candidature
jusqu'à proposer la suppression de
l'aide médicale d'État il est donc et je
le dis de façon solenelle dans ce pays
des femmes des hommes politiques qui se
disent responsables prêts à laisser sans
soin les étrangers irréguliers qu'il
faudra bien pourtant hospitaliser
lorsqu'ils seront au plus mal je le dis
c'est une absurdité de certaine façon
c'est une honte tel était d'ailleurs le
système suédois avant le déplacement en
2006 du rapporteur spécial des nations-
Unies pour le droit à la santé Paul Hunt
choqué par les méthodes discriminatoires
d'un pays se targant pourtend de sa
tradition d'accueil son rapport a permis
avec l'appui notamment de la Croix-Rouge
de changer la législation vous avez
certes simplement souhaité monsieur le
rapporteur pour avis je vous cite
envoyer un signe mais à qui au demandeur
d'asile ou simple candestin possé par
les guerres les traitements inhumains la
crise pensez-vous réellement qu'il
percevront ce signe et resteront là où
ils sont s'il s'agit de filière où le
passage est déjà monayé croyez-vous que
30 50 ou même 100 € les arrêteront ce
signe auquel vous semblez tant tenir
puisque vous y revenez est bien reçu et
par d'autres ici pour nourrir je le dis
des fantasmes des haines mais qui
risquent de vous passé nous reviendrons
sur l'article aux raisons de fond qui
sont des raisons de santé publique qui
s'opposent absolument à une telle mesure
mais aussi au coût qu'elle engendrerait
vous vous placez malheureusement à
nouveau avec cet amendement sur le
terrain de l'exclusion alors que nous
aurions pu certainement nous retrouver
sur le terrain de la rationalisation
pour améliorer si besoin et si possible
les nombreuses mesur d'ors et déjà prise
je vous
remercie la parole est à madame Aline
archimau pour le groupe
écologiste monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des finances messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues deux séries
de remarques sur les deux programmes
contenus dans cette mission santé
concernant le programme 183 intitulé
protection maladie en hausse de 13,7 %
madame la ministre tout d'abord nous
nous saluons la prise en compte de la
réalité des besoins concernant l'aide
médicale d'État et et l'augmentation de
ce budget dans la mesure où il ne sert à
rien mais nous en reparlerons euh de se
boucher les yeux et de ne pas voir cette
réalité nous nous félicitons également
que l'amélioration des délais de
traitement des dossiers du FIVA fond
d'indemnisation des victimes de la
miante dont la durée était préoccupante
il y a encore peu est été prise en
compte par une contribution spécifique
de l'état de 10 millions cet effort est
à saluer tout en restant vigilant car
suite aux travaux que j'ai pu mener sur
le sujet avec mes collègues du Sénat
dans le comité de suivi amiante je CIN
que nous n'ayons bientôt à prendre en
compte une nouvelle génération de
victimes de l' miante liée cette fois
aux conditions dans lesquelles
s'organisent trop souvent les activités
de désamiantage si des mesures
énergiques ne sont pas prises rapidement
le budget prévisionnel du programme
183 donc nous convient tout à fait nous
voterons par ailleurs contre les
amendements qui sont inscrits qui
prévoit cela a été évoqué à l'instant de
limiter l'accès tel qu'il est
actuellement réglementé pour l'aide
médicale d'État car je rappelle que cet
accès est tout à fait réglementé sous
condition de ressources des personnes
qui ont donc des revenus de moins de 780
€ par mois et qui doivent par ailleurs
répondre à des contrôles et à un certain
nombre d'autres conditions au collègues
qui comptent soutenir ces amendements je
voudrais dire au nom de notre groupe
rappeler ce que plusieurs rapports
soulignent l'instauration d'un droit de
timbre de 30 € dû par les bénéficiaires
de la l'aide médicale d'État a certes
contribué au ralentissement de
l'augmentation de la dépense liée au
dispositif en 2011 mais c c c'est une
économie en trompe lœil les personnes
concernées ont en effet reporter leurs
soins leur état de santé s'est dégradé
Infiné ils ont dû se tourner elles ont
dû se tourner vers des soins
hospitaliers beaucoup plus lourds et
donc beaucoup plus coûteux ce que
souligne d'ailleurs très bien deux
rapports rendus à ce sujet et par l'IGAS
et par l'IGF donc ces ces amendements
s'ils étaient présentés et et et et et
adoptés renvoie à des conceptions des
économies en santé publique qui sont
totalement courtermiste et totalement
contre-productive je vous renvoie à des
études récentes l'étude par exemple du
secrétariat général pour la
modernisation et l'action po de l'action
publique de 2013 qui montre combien au
contraire l'ouverture de droit d'accès à
la santé à des populations
précaires assez vite permet moins de
maladiie et donc moins de dépenses
publiques en effet derrière cet
amendement euh nous sentons euh d'abord
une position qui nous paraît pas
responsable en terme de sécurité
sanitaire des épidémies comme la
tuberculose malheureusement pour prendre
cet exemple épidémie li à la misère
non'ont pas disparu de ce pays euh nous
sentons également bien sûr sur un plan
plus politique des considérations
électorales et cette façon de vouloir en
stigmatisant des personnes
particulièrement fragiles diviser ce
pays faire croire à certains de nos
concitoyens en difficultés que ce sont
ces personnes qui sont responsables des
difficultés de ce pays nous pensons nous
aussi euh qu'il s'agit de de
propositions qui ne sont pas
responsables attention à ne pas
développer des fantasmes des haines qui
là aussi pourrait pourrai nous dépasser
concernant l'autre programme de cette
mission santé le programme 204 qui porte
sur la prévention la sécurité sanitaire
et l'offre de soins nous sommes inquiets
par la baisse de 25 % j'entends
qu'apparemment d'autres actions seront
menées dans d'autres budgets je n'ai pas
bien compris où et ça me semble particul
parulièrement inquiétant parce que il
s'agit essentiellement de baisse sur des
budgets de structure d'action de
prévention action de prévention
or nous avons compris et c'est une bonne
chose que notamment dans le prochain
projet de loi de santé publique il est
question de mettre davantage l'accent
sur la prévention et de rééquilibrer la
politique de santé entre action curative
et action préventive et et et et baisser
ces budgets là nous paraît en
contradiction totale avec cette
nécessité de développer la la la
prévention puisqueencore une fois il
s'agit quand on regarde le détail des
actions d'actions donc qui concern la
santé de population en difficulté le
programme contraception lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes contre les
mutilations sexuelles contre les risques
infectieux viage tuberculoses et autres
contre les maladies chroniques contre
les risques également liés à
l'environnement et un financement pour
le le programme national santé
environnement qui vient d'être adopté
donc il y a là nous semble-t-il une
baisse qui correspond à un arbitrage qui
nous paraît dommageable voilà quant à la
position de notre groupe nous vous
l'indiquerons plus tard elle dépendra
évidemment du texte qui sera le résultat
des débats de cette assemblée je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Laurence
Cohen pour le groupe
CRC
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre le budget de la mission santé
n'échappe pas hélas aux politiques de
restriction budgétaire nous en avons
déjà parlé en effet ce programme
prévention sécurité sanitaire et offre
de soins diminue de 25 % pour 2015 cette
réduction des moyens pour la prévention
nous paraît extrêmement préjudiciable
pour la population alors même que les
associations et les organismes de
prévention rencontrent des difficultés à
organiser leur mission ainsi en
diminuant les crédits consacrés à la
prévention des maladies chroniques de
5,6 % le risque est grand de voir se
développer certaines d'entre elles cette
baisse est d'autant plus étonnante que
ces maladies chroniques représentent les
2/ers des dépenses d'assurance maladie
madame la ministre quandant à la Réunion
par exemple le diabète touche près de 10
% de la population ne croyez-vous pas
que le rô jouer par la prévention est
primordiale pour mener une politique
efficace contre cette maladie quand les
crédits consacrés à la prévention des
risques lié à l'environnement au travail
et à l'alimentation diminue de 1,4 % ne
croyez-vous pas madame la ministre que
les travailleurs peuvent légitimement
s'inquiéter alors même que les maladies
liées au travail représentent un/5e des
dépenses de santé en diminuant les les
crédits consacré à l'éducation à la
santé de 4,2 % ce sont des missions
aussi essentielles que les actions de
prévention bucodentaire en millions en
milieu scolaire qui disparaissent
entraînant un risque sanitaire chez les
jeunes cette baisse concerne également
les actions menées pour lutter contre
les pratiques addictives et à risque là
aussi je suis inquiète de la réduction
des crédits alors même que le tabac
l'alcool les drogues continuent à faire
des ravages parmi toutes les catégories
de la population je ne manquerai pas de
développer plus avant mon propos lors de
l'examen des crédits dédiés à la mil
delka on nous renvoie souvent à la
future loi santé quand nous nous
interrogons mais cette dernière ne peut
faire TER aus fortes inquiétudes à la
lecture de ces baisses de crédit quant à
l'engagement du gouvernement dans la
prévention des maladies j'en profite
pour dire ici puisqu'une ligne
budgétaire est consacrée à la santé
mentale notamment pour soutenir les
acteurs associatifs que ce volet est
très insuffisamment traité dans le
projet de loi santé certains
professionnels demandent d'ailleurs vous
le savez madame la ministre une loi
spécifique avec des moyens à la hauteur
concernant la santé mentale en résumé
sur ce chap nous considérons que les
politiques de prévention sont un
investissement pour l'avenir en
réduisant les risques avant que les
maladies ne surviennent or la prévention
des maladies et la promotion de la santé
pour être efficace doivent être consacré
de manière globale en agissant sur les
facteurs de ris sanitair
socioéconomique d'autant que la pauvreté
est encore explosé avec
l'approfondissement de la crise je
termine sur ce programme en disant toute
mon inquiétude sur les efforts également
demandés à l'Agence nationale de
sécurité le médicament je cite en 2015
dans un contexte de rationalisation des
effectives la nm la NSM est appelé à
contribuer aux efforts d'efficience et
de productivité demandés aux opérateurs
de l'État cette efficience se traduit
par la perte de 20 emplois à temps plein
membre du conseil d'administration et
convaincu du rôle de cette agence pour
éviter de nouveaux scandales sanitaire
je ne peux qu'être perplexe à la lecture
de ces lignes venons-en au programme 183
l'effort de la solidarité nationale en
faveur de l'accès aux soins et de
l'indemnisation des publics les plus
défavorisés complète l'intervention de
la sécurité sociale à ce titre l'État
intervient pour garantir l'accès aux
soins des étrangers en situation
irrégulière et procède à la juste
indemnisation des victimes de la miante
or les crédits affectés au Fonds
d'indemnisation des victimes de la
miante demeurent identiqu à ceux de 2014
alors que le nombre des demandes
d'indemnisation a progressé de 18 %. cet
écart entre le nombre de demandeurs et
le montant versé par le fond
d'indemnisation doit nous amener à
raccourcir les délais de traitement des
demandes et renforcer les moyens des
carsates notamment cell de Nord Picardi
qui connaît des difficultés à assurer
une réponse rapide aux demandeurs enfin
permettez-moi d'aborder l'aide médicale
d'État dont nous aurons l'occasion de
rediscuter avec les amendements de
sénateur de droite en effet je voudrais
dans ce débat rappeler les raisons qui
ont poussé l'État à intervenir en
complément de l'Assurance Maladie pour
les personnes vivant sur notre
territoire historiquement la politique
d'accueil et d'asile en France a poussé
à la création d'une aide médicale
gratuite pour financer les dépenses
liées aux soins des personnes non
affiliées à l'assurance maladie sans
distinction de régularité sur le
territoire la droite et son extrême
n'ont jamais cessé de s'attaquer à ce
dispositif en stigmatisant les étrangers
qui bénéficieraient de prestations indu
je souhaiterais rappeler certaines
vérités au sujet du coût des
bénéficiaires de l'AME et des risque de
réduire le niveau de couverture des
étrangers sans papier car en période de
crise la politique du book émissaire
rencontre hélas des échos favorables
selon le rapport de liigas sur l'aide
médicale d'État de 2010 l'augmentation
des dépenses de l'Ame ne s'explique pas
par une croissance massive du nombre de
bénéficiaires puisque le nombre de
bénéficiaires de soins n'a pas connu de
progression notable ainsi près de 50 %
des bénéficiaires de l'AME ne Cour ne
recour pas aux prestations dont il
pourrait bénéficier il n'y a donc pas
contrairement à ce que répète Nicolas
Sarkozi une augmentation d'étrangers qui
viennent en France profiter de notre
générosité au contraire d'autre part si
le coût global augmente en ce qui
concerne les dépenses de l'Ame il faut
rappeler que globalement le bénéficiaire
de l'Ame consomme en moyenne 1741 € de
soins là où le bénéficiaire de la CMUC
en consomme de 1606 les prestations
servies aux bénéficiaaires de l'Ame sont
ainsi inférieures à celles dont
bénéficient les assurés CMUC alors même
que ces derniers ont droit au bénéfice
d'un panier de soins la proposition de
réduire le périmètre de couverture des
étrangers sans papier est un argument
populiste qui conduirait à des risques
sanitaires certains enfin s'agissant de
mettre un droit d'entrée pour laame cela
conduira selon le rapport de liigas au
retardement de la prise en charge
médical et donc un recours tardif à
l'hôpital nettement plus coûteux donc
quand on fait une proposition il faut en
mesurer les coûts concernant l'ensemble
de la mission santé qui malheureusement
entérine la diminution de moyens
attribué à la santé en terme de
prévention et d'éducation à la santé et
bien pour ce qui concerne notre groupe
communiste républicain et citoyens tout
cela nous conduit à voter contre ces
crédits parce qu'ils ne sont pas
suffisamment ambitieux et qu'ils ne
réond pas au besoins de notre
pays la parole est à Madame Françoise
Laborde pour le groupe
RDSE monsieur le Président Madame la
ministres mes chers collègues les
crédits de la mission santé s'élèvent
pour 2015 après de 1,2 milliards d'euros
participant ainsi à l'effort de
redressement des comptes publics ce
budget appelle quelques
observation la première porte sur le
programme prévention sécurité sanitaire
et offre de soins qui financera h
opérateurs de l'État participant à la
mise en œuvre des politiques nationales
de prévention et de sécurité
sanitaire comme l'a parfaitement
expliqué mon collègue Gilbert Barbier en
commission des affaires sociales nous a
assistons à un empilement de structure
qui empêche de distinguer exactement qui
fait quoi la mul la multiplicité des
agences sanitaires progressivement mise
en place en réponse à des crises
sanitaires spécifiques a en effet
contribué à rendre l'architecture de
notre système de sécurité sanitaire
complexe plusieurs rapports ont dénoncé
les chevauchements de compétences le
manque de transparence de lisibilité et
l'absence de coordination entre les
agents
qui ont progressivement perdu en
crédibilité c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes favorables à une
baisse du budget de fonctionnement de
ces agence qui s'inscrit dans le le
cadre de la réforme structurelle de
notre système d'agence sanitaire
question que nous aborderont lors de
l'examen du projet de loi relatif à la
santé vous envisagez notamment de créer
un institut national de prévention de
veille et d'intervention en santé
publique qui reprendra les mission
exercée par l'Institut national de
prévention et d'éducation pour la santé
l'établissement de préparation et de
réponse aux urgen sanitaires et
l'Institut de veille sanitaire vous
l'avez rappelé cette réforme permettra
d'améliorer l'efficacité de la réponse
au risques sanitaires de créer une
agence disposant d'une approche intégrée
de la santé publique et de réaliser des
économies sur les dotations à ces
opérateurs je note suite avec
satisfaction que le projet de loi de
finances pour 2015 propose à nouveau
d'amender le FIVA à hauteur de 10
millions d'euros cette mesure
emblématique vise à reconnaître la
responsabilité de l'État dans
l'indemnisation des victimes de l'amante
et c'est une très bonne
chose j'en viens enfin au dernier point
l'aide médicale d'État je suis surprise
d'entendre depuis quelques temps une
partie de l'opposition réclamer la
suppression de ce dispositif pourtant il
n'y a pas si longtemps c'était en mars
2012 pendant la campagne des élections
présidentielles Nicolas Sarkozi refusait
qu'on remette en cause cette générosité
française et y voyait même notre honneur
il promettait alors qu'il n'y toucherait
pas le discours a bien changé j'estime
que ce dispositif est
indispensable c'est à la fois une
nécessité de santé publique et une
exigence morale respectueuse des valeurs
humanistes qui sont au cœur de notre
pacte
républicain les rapporteurs de la
commission des finances et de la
commission des affaires sociales nous
proposerons tout à l'heure d'instaurer à
nouveau une franchise non plus de 30 €
comme cela existait avant 2012 mais de
50 € et de recentrer l'ame sur les soins
urgents et de prévention ainsi que sur
les publics fragiles décisions
nécessaires selon eux pour en maîtriser
le coût je rappellerai simplement qu'un
rapport des inspections générales des
affaires sociales et des Finances avait
jugé la franchise financièrement
inadapté administrativement complexe et
porteuse de risque sanitaires ce rapport
écartait en outre la la possibilité de
limiter la prise en charge aux seuls
soins urgents de telles mesures risque
en effet de générer des prises en charge
tardives et de favoriser le
développement de maladie grave ou
contagieuse les médecins eux-mêmes
estiment qu'il est préférable que les
personnes malades puissent accéder à des
soins de façon rapide pour éviter toute
propagation des maladies certes nous
savons qu'il y a des abus des dérives le
budget consacré à la me a explosé en
2013 passant de 588 à 744 millions
d'euros en l'espace d'un an et 73
400451 bénéficiaires supplémentaires ont
été recensé entre 2011 et 2013 mais
cette hausse s'explique en partie par
des filières de personnes étrangères qui
viennent se faire soigner dans certains
hôpitaux français en juin dernier devant
la commission des finances du Sénat la
ministre des Affaires sociales de la
santé et des droits des femmes s'est
engagé à lutter contre les abus
notamment en renforçant les contrôles
dans les différentses caisses primaires
d'assurance maladie elle a également
reconnu la nécessité d'enclencher très
rapidement un travail diplomatique de
coopération internationale avec les pays
d'origine je ne peux que souscrire à
cette démarche et pour toutes C ces
raisons le groupe RDSE adoptera dans sa
très grande majorité les crédits de la
mission santé je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Pascale
boattard secrétaire d'État chargée des
droits des femmes
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
les rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs la mission santé pour le
projet de loi de finance 2015 se situe
dans un contexte d'effort d'une ampleur
inédite pour le redressement des comptes
publics en matière de santé la majeure
partie des économies qui seront réalisé
concerne l'assurance maladie donc le
PLFSS marieouren a eu l'occasion de
présenter ses économies que nous allons
chercher dans la modernisation de notre
système de santé en améliorant
l'efficience de la dépense hospitalière
en agissant sur le prix des médicaments
ou encore en engageant le nécessaire
virage ambulatoire pour autant dans ce
contexte nous finançons les priorités
essentiel ainsi l'évolution des crédits
du programme 204 traduit le choix de la
prévention qui est le nôtre dans le
cadre du projet de loi relatif à la
santé présenté en Conseil des ministres
le 15 octobre dernier avec ce projet de
loi nousous pardon nous voulons
promouvoir les conditions de vie
favorables à la santé comme le font
d'autres pays avec succès dans le PLF
2015 les crédits en faveur de la
prévention de la sécurité sanitaire et
de l'offre de soins sont préservé dans
un contexte où des efforts de réduction
importants sont demander pour sur
plusieurs programmes la préservation des
crédits de prévention constitue un choix
politique fort la comparaison entre les
crédits du programme 204 entre les PLF
2014 et 2015 ne donne pas une image
exacte de l'évolution des moyens affecté
à la prévention en effet dans le PLF et
du
PLFSS 2015 nous avons rationalisé les
champs d'intervention respectif de
l'État et de la sécurité sociale cela se
traduit par le transfert de l'assurance
maladie d'un certain nombre
d'interventions les formations médical
effectué en ville le fonctionnement des
centres d'information de dépistage et de
diagnostic des infections sexuellement
transmissibles je le précise d'emblé il
ne s'agit pas de débudgétisation
comptable mais de clarification qui
visent à plus d' efficacité le transfert
du financement des formations médicales
en ville peut peut permettre d'en
améliorer et simplifier la gestion le
transfert du financement des sidistes
permet la fusion entre les les
structures financées par l'assurance
maladie et au-delà de poser les bases
d'un dispositif unique de dépistage plus
performant et plus accessible au public
qui en ont le plus besoin cette réforme
du dépistage a été salué par les par
l'association AIDS comme une petite
révolution dans la façon d'appréhender
le dépistage des hépatites et du VIH en
France si on tient compte de ces
transferts et si on compare les moyens
consacrés en 2015 sur le périmètre qui
était celui du programme 204 en 2014 on
constate une progression de 0,87 % ce
qui encore une fois dans un contexte de
réduction de dépenses de l'État traduit
un choix politique fort le soutien
budgétaire de l'État à la politique de
prévention passe principalement par la
dootation du programme 204 au projets
régionaux de santé dans le cadre du fond
d'intervention régionale c'est créd
resteront sur toute la durée du triénal
au niveau de la LFI 2014 soit plus de
130 millions d'euros je rappelle que le
financement des actions de prévention du
FIR euh bénéficie des ressources de
l'Assurance Maladie pour un total de 247
millions d'euros en 2014 par ailleurs
les financements du fond de prévention
de la CNAM TS progresseront dans le
cadre de la nouvelle COG de 7,3 % entre
2013 et 2017 de
424,6 millions d'euros à
455,4 millions
d'euros en dehors du financement des
actions de prévention les opérateurs de
sécurité sanitaire et prévention
contribue sur la durée du triénal aux
efforts d'économie mais ces dernières
reposent non sur durabo mais sur une
réforme structurelle de notre système
d'agence sanitaire en effet la la future
loi relative à la santé crée un institut
national de prévention de veille et
d'insertion en santé publique reprenant
les missions exercées par l'inpest les
Prusses et
l'InVS cette réforme doit permettre
d'améliorer l'efficacité de la réponse
au risqu sanitaire de créer une agence
disposant d'une approche intégrée de la
santé publique et permet également de
réaliser des économies sur les dotations
de ces opérateurs en ce qui concerne les
agences sanitaires précisément monsieur
le sénateur Savari en effet le projet de
loi de santé entend permettre la
rationalisation de l'organisation des
agences sanitaires nationales les débats
autour de la loi santé permettront
d'entrer dans le détail des intentions
du Gouvernement nous avons d'ors et déjà
indiqué que nous ambitionns de créer une
grande agence de la veille sanitaire de
la prévention de la gestion des crises
sanitaires elle regroupera
progressivement les compétences de
l'Institut de veille sanitaire de
l'Institut National de Prévention
l'éducation de la santé et de
l'établissement de préparation et de
répondre aux urgences sanitaires nos
objectifs de rationalisation ne sont
donc pas motivés à titre principal par
la recherche d'économie mais par le
souci de donner plus de force et de
cohérence à notre politique de santé
contribuer donc aux efforts d'économie
tout en finançant les priorités c'est
également le sens de notre action au
sein du programme 183 avant d'envenir au
financement de l'aide médicale d'État
qui je le sais vous passionne je
souhaiterais euh souligner dans le cadre
du PLF 2015 l'état rétablit sa
contribution au FIVA qui avait été mise
à zéro en 2013 et 2014 cette
contribution sera de 10 millions d'euros
il y a là non seulement un symbole la
reconnaissance de la responsabilité de
l'État dans l'indemnisation des victimes
de l' miante mais aussi l'accompagnement
de l'action que nous menons pour
améliorer l'efficacité du fond
d'indemnisation des victimes de l'
miante en réduisant les délais de
présentation et de paiement des offres
d'indemnisation j'en viens à présent à
l'aide médicale d'État je souhaiterais
tout d'abord rappeler la vérité des
chiffres en 2015 nous prévoyons 678
millions d'euros de crédit pour l'ame
nous sommes donc très loin des chiffres
que certains font claquer dans les
médias je
comprends que les compétitions internes
dans certains partis politiques
conduisent à une surenchère qui m'a mais
il m'a semblé nécessaire dans ce débat
d'en rester au fait cette dépense
garantit un accès aux soins aux
étrangers en situation irrégulière
c'est-à-dire des personnes qui ne sont
pas des assurés sociaux parce que cela
correspond certes à nos valeurs mais
aussi parce que c'est dans l'intérêt de
la santé publique de toutes et tous cela
ne sifit pas que que l'ame ne doit pas
être ne doit doit être exempté de
l'effort d'économie mais de façon plus
spécifique l'ame nous devons travailler
sur les questions de filières
effectivement organisées qui ont pu être
entre guillemet repéré dans certaines
villes de notre territoire et qui par
des filières organisées de séjours
uniquement motivé par le soit de
bénéficier d'une prise en charge des
soins une chose est de prendre en charge
les soins donnés à des personnes déjà
présentes sur notre territoire c'est une
reconnaissance d'un état de fait et
c'est du pragmatisme une autre et de
laisser se développer des entrées sur le
territoire qui n'ont pour but que de
bénéficier de la prise en charge des
soins lutter contre ce phénomène
s'inscrit dans la lutte plus général des
réseaux mafieux de l'immigration
illégale mais peut également passer à
une action de coopération avec les pays
d'origine en tout état de cause je vous
rappelle que les personnes dans notre
pays qui contribuent à financer la
sécurité sociale sont les Français bien
évidemment sont aussi les étrangers en
situation régulière mais je vous
rappelle aussi que certains étrangers en
situation irrégulière mais employés de
façon régulière il contribuent aussi
c'était une petite précision je tenais à
vous apporter je vous
remercie nous allons procéder à l'examen
des amendements portant sur les crédits
de la mission santé figurant à l'état B
à l'article 32 je suis
de deux amendements faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune le 161 n'est
pas
soutenu la parole est à Monsieur delâre
au nom de la commission des finances
pour le
68 c'est pas le même parce que je crois
queion communes sont quand même très
différents chersègues agit simplement de
ramener les autorisationsengagement les
crédits de paiement à
chiffre qui revient en fait au chiffre
de 2008 madame la ministre alors je
voudais bien savoir quand ce qui s'est
passé depuis 2008 qui puisse nous
expliquer que ces crédits ont augmenté
d'environ 50 % alors ne nous dites pas
que c'est les persécutions parce que les
gens qui sont persécutés c'est vrai nous
vivons des
moments historiques parfaitement
compliqués et difficiles mais dès lors
que vous déposez un dossier de demande
d'asile immédiatement vous avez droit à
la CMU donc ils ne font pas partie de
des personnes qui qui sont soumises à
laame si vous pensez si vous pensez tous
qu'il y a pas de problème avec l'aide
médicale d'État je vous invite aller
dans
dans les bnes d'accès des hôpitaux voir
les gens qui accueillent voir comment ça
se passe parce que nous sommes sur ce
dossier presque accusé de
populiste
en dans un nous sommes dans le déniis de
réalité la réalité c'est
que les la moitié des personnes qui sont
à l'accueil de deux grands hôpitaux de
mon département je peux vous dire que
elle m'ont expliqué comment elle votait
tellement les abus leur semble
totalement incontrôlé parce qu'en
réalité la personne seule en situation R
ne vient pas toute seule ils viennent à
78 à 10 et ils exigent c'est comme ça
que ça se passe est-ce que vous avez
l'air
d'ignorer
je je je je
prétends que si nous ne réagissions pas
tous collectivement sur ce type de
dossier de façon raisonnable je pense
que vous allez c'est là en ne pas
réagissant en ne pas en refusant de
reconnaître parce que vous savez aussi
il y a aussi des sansroit dans ce pays
c'est-à-dire des personnes des familles
qui ont cotisé 20 30 ans et ils arrivent
à un moment donné avec la période que
vous connaissez eu il n'ont plus aucun
droit et quand on leur explique que
l'étranger en situation régulière lui il
a le droit dans certaines conditions
certes à l'accès ça pose problème et je
crois que tout les républicains devant
ce genre de de de difficulté doivent
réfléchir moi je peux vous dire dans mon
département dans ma ville j'affronte
régulièrement dans des triangulaires le
Front national
oui et ben je sais les thématiques qui
le dispense je sais les traces que ça
reste et je peux vous dire qu'il est
temps de réagir si le gouvernement
l'entend pas nous prendrons nous les
initiatives pour réagir on ne supprime
pas les crédits on vous dit on vous
demande de travailler sérieusement sur
cette question ici au Sénat le groupe
udi le groupe UMP cet amendement est un
amendement d'appel vous dire
attention alors on écrit au ministre
monsieur monsieur l'orateur du groupe
socialiste il me dit on rentre dans
l'exclusion on aurait pu rentrer dans
dans dans dans un travail commun quand
le rapporteur du du dossier écrit au
ministre il y a aucun signe aucune
réaction qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire on
doit laisser courir et ben non nous
allons réagir désormais nous réagissons
parce que cette question nous semble
essentielle alors
le il faut quand même dire aussi deux
trois mots parce que nous sommes la
commission des finances c'est c'est très
bien de dire qu'on est le plus généreux
de l'Europe le plus généreux du monde
mais comment on paye cette générosité à
crédit est-ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
continuer éternellement à faire le
progrès social à crédit je en vous
regardant sous j'aurais j'aurais
j'aurais j'aurais le sentiment dire
Rocard revient on n pas les moyens vous
savez plus que de de de de d'accueillir
toute la misère du monde oui oui oui ben
c'est mon voisin je pense que c'est mon
voisin il connaît les les projets les
difficultés peut-être un peu mieux que
certains d'ici alors je trouve que de ne
pas vouloir même réagir et de s'envoyer
les mots de populiste à la mot parce
qu'on peut tous en conscience dire que
c'est un vrai problème et que ce vrai
problème mérite mieux que les habit
invectiv
alors vous voulez de trois chiffres qui
vous intéressent sur sur le le le PLFSS
est-ce que vous pensez que l'assurance
est maladie est équilibrée non au
minimum on r Oui il y a un
ralentissement de la dépense et la cadè
qui depuis des années récupère tous les
déficits elle est à 160 milliards de
dettes et la
CSE oui nous nous énervons pas la
responsabilité elle est sûrement
partagée et la CSE la CSE c'est quand
même incroyable la CSE vous savez c'est
la centre de compensation de tous les
régimes 34 milliards pour faire la
trésorerie d'emprunt alors c'est très
facile de dire
aujourd'hui le progrès social nous
sommes les plus généux du monde sauf que
nous sommes au bout de nous sommes près
de la faillite budgétaire aussi bien
pour le PLFSS que pour le budget de
l'État et vous savez très bien
qu'aujourd'hui on s'en sort que parce
que les marchés font qu'on prête de
l'argent à 1 % est-ce que vous pensez
qu'on peut continuer endetter la cadesse
au rythme où ça va sans faire imploser
le système le moment venu alors voilà un
amendement de raison qui tient compte de
l'environnement général de
l'environnement sociologique de la
réalité du terrain la le dénis de
réalité ça permet de vivre tranquille
mais le de réalité quand vous êtes maire
dans les communes où nous sommes
quelques-uns c'est c'est ce sont des
vrais réalité et notre et notre
responsabilité c'est d'ici d'en parler
correctement et de prendre prend
d'essayer de prendre les initiatives qui
correspondent à des vrais problèmes
alors je reviens maintenant plus
techniquement à
l'amendement je pense que tout le monde
a compris que nous voulons réduire de de
millions la dotation sans toucher à à
laame dite de droit commun qui
correspond à ce que vous avez dit
Monsieur le rapporte enfin l'orateur du
groupe socialiste on y touche pas nous
ne touchons pas aux urgences nous nous
souhaitons simplement pouvoir travailler
correctement sur un sujet difficile et
c'est un amendement qui appelle à une
réflexion tous ensemble si c'est
possible en attendant comme le ministre
ne semble même pas nous nous répondre
comme vous dites il faut quand même
savoir que dans le budget rectificatif
qui arrive la semaine prochaine laame il
y a plus de 150 millions d'euros
supplémentaires d'affecter bien sûr et
ben ça mérite quand même qu'on puisse en
discuter avec le gouvernement voilà
l'objectif de cet amendement et mes
chers collègues je vous demande
naturellement tous sans exception
naturellement à le voter pour qu'on
puisse travailler tous ensemble dans les
semaines qui viennent comme l' dit merci
monsieur le rapporteur avis du
gouvernement madame la
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur je vais peut-être
vous apporter quelques éléments déjà de
précision d'abord les demandeurs d'asile
ne font pas partie de laame monsieur le
rapporteur non ce sont les les étrangers
en situation irrégulière lorsqu'on est
demandeur de droit d'asile
lorsqu'on est demandeur de droit d'asile
on a un statut qui n'est pas celui
d'étranger en situation irrégulière
monsieur est-ce que est-ce que je peux
est-ce que je peux essayer ministre la
parole est à madame la ministre n'est
pas la CMU
monsieur mais vous vous s'il vous plaît
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre vous donnez des leçons à tout
le monde monsieur le sénateur mais je
vois que vous avez un petit problème
pour écouter les autres donc
calmons-nous tout cela est une question
très intéressante et à laquelle il faut
apporter des réponses précises parce que
effectivement la confusion permet ne
permet pas d'avoir un débat serein et
d'y trouver des solutions et au
contraire d'alimenter les peurs et les
confusions totales qui peuvent y avoir
quand on apporte des mauvaises réponses
en tout cas des réponses qui ne sont pas
les vraies réponses parce que ce ne sont
pas les bons éléments ça c'est une
première chose vous dites et bien les
bénéficiaires de l'AME ont beaucoup
augmenté c'est vrai en partie
et pourquoi et bien parce que à force de
repousser la réforme du droit d'asile on
a laissé depuis 10 ans de beaucoup de
demandeurs d'asile attendent jusqu'à 2
ans une réponse quant à leur demande et
que s'est-il passé parce qu'en 2 ans il
s'en passe des choses dans la vie des
hommes et des femmes qui sont demandeur
d'asile ils sont peut-être mariés ils
ont peut-être eu des enfants et ainsi de
suite et bien une fois qu'ils ont une
réponse négative ils souhaitent rester
sur le terr teritoire et ils deviennent
en situation irrégulière et donc
s'inscrivent à la me c'est pour cela que
nous voulons aussi réformer le droit
d'asile pour deux raisons mais parce que
nous avons le respect de ces personnes
qui font ces demandes et qui ont besoin
d'être fixé très rapidement quant à leur
sort notamment de savoir s'ils relèvent
du droit d'asile et qu'il peuvent
justement en situation régulière accéder
à un emploi pouvoir cotiser d'ailleurs
au à la sécurité sociale à la retraite
pour pouvoir travailler sur notre
territoire et ceux qui n'y ont qui ont
une réponse négative de ne pas justement
se retrouver après dans des situations
où il il leur est quasi impossible
humainement de repartir pour des raisons
diverses et variées voilà dans les
réponses que je peux vous apporter et
qui elles pour le coup répondent à des
situations qu'on peut constater tous les
jours pour celles et ceux qui s sont un
petit peu intéressés de façon sérieuse
quant à la CMU je suis ravi vie euh vous
savez il n'y a pas de sans droit dans
notre pays parce qu'il existe justement
la CMU et que la CMU et CMUC a été créé
dans euh lorsque Lionel Jospin était
premier ministre et que ça a été une
très grande avancée de la gauche
plurielle à l'époque et euh il ne me
semble pas que ce au-delà de la gauche
pleur beaucoup de personnes avaient voté
ce texte à l'époque mais je suis ravi
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde en soit
d'accord et puis une dernière chose ça
apparaîtra peut-être comme un slogan
mais c'est quand même une réalité pour
donner l'image un petit peu de tout cela
vous savez les virus n'ont pas de
frontièrees ils n'ont pas de papier non
plus et lorsque ils touchent des
personnes et bien c'est de façon non
distincte et il faut bien dans les
premières dans les premiers temps d'une
maladie vous le savez très bien soigner
les personnes pour pas justement et bien
au-delà des coûts qui sont effectivement
une donnée qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui puisque nous sommes dans le
cadre de la loi de finance aussi sur le
plan humain et bien nous préférons avoir
des personnes en bonne santé qu'en
mauvaise
santé je vais mettre au voix la parole
est à Madame agès canailler pour
explication de
vote monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre mes chers collègues alors
effectivement la question de l'aide
médicale d'État est un sujet euh
important un sujet essentiel notamment
quand on voit euh qu'effectivement les
crédits sont en augmentation de 12 %
pour 2015 après avoir progressé plus de
17 % ces ces trois dernières années et
que la somme allouée de 678 millions
inscrit pour 2015 et tout à fait
sous-évalué par rapport à la réalité du
terrain alors il ne s'agit pas de
chercher des bous émissaires ou de
stigmatiser des personnes mais il suivit
de mettre en place il convient de mettre
en place des réponses non seulement
précises madame le ministre mais surtout
pragmatiques en effet notre pays ne doit
pas rester passif alors que nos voisins
européens agissent en mettant des
conditions d'accès plus restrictives
nous devons nous montrer responsable
pour pouvoir continuer à assurer un
niveau de protection sociale élevé à
tous nos compatriotes alors au nom du
groupe je tiens à saluer le travail qui
a été mené par notre rapporteur spécial
Francis de lâre et par le rapporteur
pour avis René Paul Savari qui eux ont
cherché des solutions pragmatiques pour
contenir cette progression avec d'une
part l'instauration d'une participation
annuelle de 50 € qui est une mesure
d'équité vis-à-vis nos concitoyens qui
doivent s'acquitter des franchises
médicales et d'autre part avec cet
amendement grâce au recentrage de
l'accès gratuit à tous les soins donc le
vote du groupe UMP sera favorable sur
cet amendement
merci la parole est à Monsieur Vincent
capauanellas pour explication de
vote merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues monsieur
le monsieur le rapporteur nous sommes je
crois sur un un un débat qui peut-être
un faux débat s'il se limite à des
postures et qui peut être au contraire
un débat de fond si on veut bien aborder
un sujet difficile en dépassant l'éch
médiatique qui a été évoqué ici et là et
en regardant un certain de difficultés
en face car elles existe il nous faut je
crois conjuguer à la fois le respect de
principe et puis la volonté de voir en
face un certain nombre de réalités je
vais d'abord apporter une précision
madame la ministre nous avons tout à
l'heure entendu Francis de lâre et nous
l'avons entendu nous dire clairement que
les ressortissants du droit d'asile
bénéficiaient de la CMU et ne nous a pas
parlé de l'Ame s'agissant des
ressortissants du droit d'asile en tout
cas on été plusieurs à l'entendre très
clairement donc je veux lui donner acte
de de ceci et contredire pardon votre
explication qui a été donnée à l'instant
je disais qu'il fallait essayer de
concilier les principes et bien sûr voir
les réalités et j'ai entendu là encore
le rapporur nous dire tout à l'heure que
l'ame je le cite est indispensable et
qu'il ne souhaite pas le rejet des
crédits et donc si la majorité
sénatoriale ouvre le débat c'est dans
ces termes là qui sont ceux du
rapporteur l'ame est indispensable et
nous souhaitons pas le rejet des crédits
le rapporteur a également appelé tout à
l'heure clairement je cite encore ces
mots à une redéfinition des critères et
c'est de ça dont nous souhaitons parler
de voir quel est le panier de soins
comment on peut traiter une ame qui soit
humaniste mais une ame qui réponde aussi
un peu mieux à un certain nombre de
critères et enfin je voudrais dire que
le rapporteur a également parlé d'un
amendement fort d'appel là encore je le
cite j'ai noté mot àot il a parlé d'un
amendement fort d'appel et nous avons
bien conscience que le travail de
navette doit permettre aussi que les
positions peut-être évoluent mais de
part et d'autrre et ça veut dire que
nous pensons qu'on ne peut pas rester
dans le déniis et simplement ce qui nous
étonne c'est que quand la nouvelle
majorité est arrivée aux affaires elle a
abrogé un certain nombre de dispositions
qui avaient été mises en œuvre avant
elle les a abrogé pour des raisons de
principe mais les réalités sont malgré
tout là et donc nous pensons que cette
position là doit bien sûr évoluer et
quand le rapporteur parle de
l'amendement fort d'appel je crois que
cette phrase là elle a du sens nous
pensons qu'au-delà de l'amendement il y
a un travail sans doute qu'il faut
approfondir avec les praticiens il y a
peut-être une mission à refaire il y a
de rapports qui sont intervenus qui
doivent intervenir il y a place
évidemment pour le débat nous savons
tous que évidemment les médecins
considère que chaque homme a droit à des
soins et que c'est pas forcément les
réalités comptables qui V intervenir
là-dessus bien évidemment et c'est le
servment d'Hippocrate et c'est leur
honneur et nous le savons pour autant
nous avons ici l'obligation sur un
certain nombre de question de soins
aussi de fixer un nombre de règles donc
c'est tout le débat qui est pas un débat
plus simple pas si simple que ça pardon
ensuite j'ai entendu certains orateurs
nous dire tout à l'heure quelle que soit
l'intention elle ne peut être dissociée
de la surenchère médiatique là encore
j'ai noté mot à mot si on se dit que
quel que soit l'intention on ne peut pas
la dissocier de l'UR enchè médiatique
dans ce cas-là on va s'interdire
d'évoquer plein de sujets en se disant
après et tout finalement mieux vaut la
politique de l'autruche parce que ce
sujet là pourrait prêter à caricature je
pense que le rôle du Sénat en
particulier et le rôle des assemblées en
général mais ici on essaie de le faire
souvent c'est d'essayer de faire la part
entre justement l'éco médiatique la
mousse médiatique et un certain nombre
de dispositions qu'il faut discuter ici
et trouver même sur des sujets aigus
peut-être parfois les éléments de
consensus alors ici auocna en tout cas
on peut me semble-t-il si
essayer je crois que nous sommes aussi
nombreux à convenir j'ai entendu quand
même sous des formes assez différentes
que le sujet doit évoluer c'estd que peu
de gens disent ici après tout laame il
faut rien changer tout va très bien et
tout le monde se dit il y a quand même
des sujets madame la ministre nous a dit
tout à l'heure je en temps un peu
différent j'en conviens qu'il y avait
des filières qu'il fallait aussi traiter
les questions de filières mais nous nous
traitons pas laame sous la rubrique
immigration nous traitons laame sous la
rubrique santé et dans cette optique là
d'humanisme et de respect d'un C n de
règles nous ne souhaitons en rien
stigmatiser nous ne sommes pas
favorables à quelque stigmatisation que
ce soit en direction de quelque public
que ce soit on est certain ici à être
élu de département d'ailleurs moi en
particulier en Sani où la question de la
prise en charge des soins est une vraie
question doit être traitée vraiment sur
le fond je vouais simplement dire que on
a abordé ces questions aussi en
regardant les comparaisons
internationales on a vu que l'Espagne a
évolué récemment notamment sur ce sujet
et qu'elle a revu drastiquement les
conditions d'accès aux soins gratuits
pour les populations en 2012
principalement en raison de la
problématique financière et quand on se
compare on VO bien quand même que la
France se distingue par le très large
accès qui est donné aux soins gratuits
je dire également que la forte
progression du programme maladie 13,7 %
résulte en quasi totalité de l'évolution
des crédit de laame et que à l'exception
de l'exercice 2012 les crédits consommés
ont toujours été supérieurs d'ailleurs
au crédit votés ça a été rappelé le
nombre de bénéficiaires en fait on le sa
accru d'environ 130000 130000 depuis
2002 je vais conclure lement en disant
que il nous semble que des ajustements
complémentaires sont nécessaires et
qu'il devront bien sûr préserver le
double objectif humanitaire et sanitaire
du dispositif d'abord protéger les
personnes et répondre à l'objectif
sanitaire du fait qu'il n'y ait pas de
contagion mais d'abord protéger les
personnes et en même temps fixer des
règles pour tout le monde merci merci
mon chers collègue la parole est à
Monsieur kucci pour explication de
vote
non madame la ministre sincèrement oui
d'accord on nous dit c'est un débat très
médiatique enfin c'est pas le seul par
conséquent il faut se dire les choses et
j'entendais notre collègue madame
Laborde dire elle-même tout à l'heure
dans son intervention que le nombre
de bénéficiaires de laame avait augmenté
de 71000 en un an par conséquent quand
on nous dit non non le nombre n'augmente
pas c'est la charge qui augmente non le
nombre de bénéficiaires de laame
augmente et il augmente pour une raison
mécanique c'est que on dit et on a dit
tout à l'heure et le rapporteur a
excellemment dit que ceux qui
bénéficient du droit d'asile ensuite ont
la CMU naturellement
mais en réalité ceux qui sont déboutés
et qui deviennent de fait des entre
guillemets sans papierers cela passe à
laame et comme le nombre de demandeurs
d'asile augmente considérablement depuis
5 ans et que nous sommes aux alentours
de 70000 et que après l'OFPRA et la CNDA
on donne à peu près 12 à 13000 titres de
réfugiés ça veut dire que chaque année
mécaniquement on crée 50 à 55000
personnes à qui on est on n pas accepté
le droit d'asile et on enacompagne à peu
près 10 à 15000 donc mécaniquement notre
système est fou parce que on n pas de
conditions d'entrer sur les demandes
d'asile avec des des des critères
suffisants en réalité on fabrique
presque
mécaniquement des futurs titulaires de
la me donc il y a un problème je dis pas
moi qu'il faut remettre en cause la
totalité du principe et cetera bien sûr
que non et je ne remettrai certainement
pas en cause le serment d'Hippocrate et
le fait que les médecins soignent mais
quand on arrive à des niveaux tels parce
que madame la ministre vous dites parce
que c'est écrit que euh l'année
prochaine on met un peu moins par
rapport à ce qui était mais la réalité
elle n'est pas là et vous le savez bien
vous savez bien que depuis plusieurs
années on inscrit au budget un chiffre
pour la me qui n'est pas respecté et que
systématiquement en fin d'année on fait
un complément et que régulièrement
aujourd'hui sur tous ces thèmes
d'ailleurs c'est ridicule je l'ai dit
dans mon rapport sur le droit d'asile et
sur l'immigration donnons les vrais
chiffres parlons clairement rien n'est
pire que le faux semblant ou le mensonge
dans le débat public parce que quand il
y a faux semblant au mensonge on donne
tous les prétextes aux extrêmes alors
qu'on dirait clairement voilà combien ça
coûte voilà comment on peut mettre les
critères voilà comment on peut maîtriser
les gens raisonnables trouveraient un
accord mais à force de ne pas vouloir
parce que si on touche à la me on est
forcément xénophobe et tout ce qu'on
veut parce que si on veut toucher à ça
c'est absolument insupportable on est
inhumain et tout mais ça n'a pas de sens
parce que ça pousse à la cristallisation
un point tel que ça finira et ça finit
dans le débat public par la force de
ceux qui disent supprimons la me donc
moi je je ne comprends pas l'amendement
de notre excellent collègue Francis
deâre cet amendement il met pas en cause
ni le le l'hospitalisation d'urgence ni
les soins d'urgence il met pas en cause
un certain nombre de choses qu'est-ce
qu'il met en cause en réalité c'est ce
qu'on appelle pardon de le dire je l'ai
dit en commission des finances à Marie
soltoen il met en cause ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui avec une élégance rare le
tourisme médical c'estàdire il met en
cause ces filières qui organise ici et
là un peu partout dans le monde le fait
qu'on dit ben allez donc en France ils
ont un système de santé un système
hospitalier remarquable et c'est un
compliment à l'égard du système français
mais en plus avec l'ame bah ça vous
coûte rien donc dans dans ces conditions
on est devenu fou enfin je veux dire je
on n'est pas là pour dire il y a du mal
dans le monde on le refuse on vous dit
seulement on ne peut pas être le système
hospitalier sursaturé en ce moment par
ces réseaux qui organisent le tourisme
médical sur notre pays alors oui à une
ame cohérente par rapport aux besoins
par rapport aux soins d'urgence et
cetera non à ce qui est en réalité le
surcou lié au réseau donc je voterai
naturellement l'amendement de Francis
delat et et je dis sincèrement madame la
ministre
si on continue obstinément à ne pas
vouloir débattre du niveau financier des
critères de l'encadrement et bien vous
mettez sur la scène publique un débat
qui est totalement dénaturé et qui va
donner aux extrêmes tous les arguments
de la terre alors qu'on peut
parfaitement entre gens un peu pondérés
trouver une solution donc oui je voterai
cet amendement la parole est à Madame
Catherine
Génisson
oui merci Monsieur monsieur le Président
je voudrais d'abord commencer en disant
à à monsieur le rapporteur que quand on
cite et souvent on cite Michel Rocard de
façon incomplète parce que on cite
toujours que la première moitié de la
phrase de Michel Rocard qui dit que qui
disait qu'effectivement notre pays ne
pouvait pas accueillir toute la misère
du monde mais qu'en contrepartie il
était fondamental de s'occuper de la
coopération internationale et en
particulier de la coopération nord-
sudud et de mettre en place toutes les
politiques de coopération donc je pense
que il ne faut pas faire référence de
façon détournée à à un homme qui a
marqué vraiment je dire la politique de
notre pays et la politique sociale et
socialiste de notre pays la deuxième
chose que je voudrais dire c'est
qu'effectivement il faut avoir un débat
de fond sur l'aide médicale d'État et le
débat de fond a commencé d'ailleurs
grâce à l'un de vos collègues à
l'Assemblée nationale un sénate un
député UMP qui s'appelle Claude pardon
Claude guasgen et qui s'étonnait que les
dépenses d'ame estent augmenté de façon
très importante après l'instauration de
l'ame et laame ayant été instaurée dans
les années 2000 il a donc fait un
rapport avec un collègue du groupe
socialiste dont j'ai oublié le nom je ne
sais pas si c'est pas c'était pas
monsieur CUG mais enfin peu importe et
en fait il a reconnu que cette
augmentation de l'aide médicale d'État
était dû au fait que on commençait
seulement à quantifier et à codifier les
dépenses consacrées à l'aide médicale
d'État c'est-à-dire qu'auparavant les
hôpitaux jouaient leur rôle
d'hospitalité jouaient leur rôle
d'hospitalité d'hospice au sens lointain
du terme tel que qu'on les entendait et
qu'enfin on comptabilisait l'aide
médicale d'État alors c'est vrai que au
fil des années le le le le compte de
l'aide médicale d'État a très largement
augmenté mais c'est d'abord un sujet et
je rejoins un peu notre collègue c'est
d'abord un sujet de de d'émigration
c'est d'abord un sujet de droit d'asile
et je pense qu'on pourra traiter
correctement du sujet de l'aide médicale
d'État quand nous aurons et madame la
ministre nous a annoncé ces textes de
loi qui vont arriver de façon très
prochaine je pense qu'il y a
effectivement à réformer le la demande
de droit d'asile car ça ça aboutit
effectivement à des dérives qui sont qui
sont difficiles et qui sont d'abord
difficiles pour celles et ceux qui les
vivent je crois que c'est quand même
cela qu'il faut d'abord dire en premier
alors après il y a peut-être des
irrégularités et bien évidemment contre
les réseaux il faut lutter il faut
lutter contre les réseaux mais j'ai
envie de dire que ces personnes qui sont
qui qui qui qui souhaitent être éligible
à l' à l'AME quand elles sont issues de
réseau elles sont aussi accueillies par
des personnes par du personnel soignant
qui n'ignorent pas qu'elles sont issues
des réseaux et là je pense qu'il faut
savoir dire que les responsabilités sont
partagées et ça effectivement il faut
lutter implacablement contre les fraudes
parce que la fraude est la première
source d'inégalité entre nos concitoyens
je crois qu'il faut le souligner alors
après après monsieur le rapporteur je
pense que nous habitons nous n'habitons
pas dans dans les mêmes régions et en ce
qui en ce qui me concerne et je parle de
l'intérieur parce que je suis médecin
j'ai exercé des responsabilités dans les
médecines dans la médecine d'urgence
j'ai exercé des responsabilités en tant
que praticienne au SAMU du pas decaléis
et je peux vous dire vous garantir que
les migrants qui sont à calé qui sont
malheureusement pour eux j'ai envie de
dire éligibles à laame ne sont pas des
personnes qui frôent ne sont pas des
personnes qui exagèrent ils sont des
personnes qui sont en détresse morale en
détresse sociale et en détresse
sanitaire dramatique et ils ne vont pas
même spontanément dans les hôpitaux ils
sont en général amenés dans les hôpitaux
par par les pompiers parce que les
pompiers ont été appelés par les
citoyens et vous pourrez demander à
votre collègue maire de Calais qui qui
connaît parfaitement la situation ce
sont des personnes qui sont dans la
détresse la plus complète donc je pense
que bien et et ce pourquoi parce que
nous connaissons des conflits Inter
nationaux qui sont dramatiques quand on
voit les les témoignages de Syriens
quand on voit les témoignages
d'éritréens quand on voit les
témoignages d'Afghans ce sont des
témoign des témoignages de personnes qui
sont dans la détresse la plus absolue et
que il est et c'est une fierté
républicaine j'ai envie de dire que de
les accueillir que de les accueillir là
où ils doivent pouvoir être soignés et
en particulier dans nos hôpitaux et en
particulier dans les dans les dans les
hôpitaux publics alors je pense qu'il
faut qu'il faut rester serein sur ce
débat et j'ai envie de dire que les
amendements sont inopportuns qu'il y ait
un un débat que nous débattions que sur
le sujet de laame bien évidemment mais
que l'on que l'on présente des
amendements qui qui n'aboutiront pas on
le sait bien qu'ils n'aboutiront pas
parce qu'ils ne correspondent pas à la
réalité tant qu' en ce qui concerne la
diminution des crédits de la me ça a été
dit d'ailleurs on sait très bien que les
crédits de laame ne sont pas en
diminution et par ailleurs quand quand
quand on on l'évoquera tout à l'heure le
sujet d'un fort fait avant de pouvoir
être éligible aux soins aux soins
couverts par le par l'ame je pense pense
que ces amendements sont infondés et ils
entretiennent ils entretiennent même si
ce n'est pas la volonté des sénateurs
ici présents dans cet hémicycle un
climat délétaire un climat malsin pour
l'opinion publique pour nos concitoyens
et je pense que ce n'est pas de la sorte
qu'il faut qu'il faille aborder aborder
le débat alors oui continuons de
travailler sur l'aide médicale d'État je
pense que le vrai sujet c'est d'abord le
sujet du droit d'asile le sujet des des
des migrations de nos populations en
tenant compte aussi de notre politique
étrangère que nous menons que mène
l'ensemble des pays je pense que c'est
un débat qui est qui va très au-delà de
la de la mission santé que nous étudions
aujourd'hui mais en ce qui concerne la
mission santé soyez soyez assurés
qu'avec mon collègue que je nomme
d'ailleurs Yve dedign puisque monsieur
le rapporteur semblait avoir oublié son
nom nous voterons avec le groupe
socialiste nous voterons bien évidemment
contre tous ces amendements merci la
parole est à madame Aline archimau pour
explication de vote
oui on peut on peut bien sûr il faut
travailler toujours à à améliorer les
dispositifs et et et celui de laame
comme les autres
simplement je pense que enfin certains
propos ont fait quasiment l'amalgame
entre ce qui peut exister de de de
réseau mafieux dans ce secteur comme
dans d'autres hein à ce qui relève de la
fraude dans ce secteur comme dans
d'autres et à ce qui est quand même la
la grande majorité des des populations
qui arrive euh par exemple dans les
urgences il se trouve que dans le cadre
d'une mission j'ai j'ai rencontré pas
mal de de personnels et d'équipes qui
travaillent dans les services d'urgence
et qui et qui vous explique que euh ces
personnes si elles pouvaient être
soignées et suivies en amont elles
arriveraient euh moins euh moins malade
ce que je voulais dire donc c'est que
notre groupe écologiste votera contre
contre ces amendements d'une part parce
qu'il il n'engage pas le débat euh il
n'engage pas le travail sur des bases
euh correctes euh la solution qui est
qui est proposée là c'est une solution à
la fois je le redis inefficace et
coûteuse elle est inefficace et coûteuse
parce que contrairement à ce que prétend
euh le monsieur le rapporteur de la
commission des finances elle nous coûte
ça nous coûterait très cher de
restreindre l'accès à laame puisque donc
les gens arriveraient et je vous renvoie
alleer discuter avec des services dans
les urgences arriveraient dans des
situations avec des pathologies beaucoup
plus lourdes parce que pas soigné en
amont et donc beaucoup plus cher elles
sont d'autre part ces solutions
dangereuses parce que porteuse de risque
sanitair réel j'ai cité la tuberculose
il y en a d'autres sont des maladies
contagieuses que nous avons tout à fait
intérêt à à à juguler et ce n'est pas en
restreignant l'accès aux soins de ces
personnes qu'on va les juguler on va
faire exactement le contraire d'autre
part sur un autre plan euh ces
amendements en effet ne sont pas ne sont
pas au parce que implicitement que les
collègues le veuillent ou non
implicitement il cible des populations
particulièrement fragiles dont on sait
bien qu'elles sont chassées par tous les
conflits mondiaux les guerres par la fin
qu'elles sont là et qu'elles sont par ce
type d'amendement parce que c'est
finalement le seul amendement que vous
faites alors que il y aurait sans doute
beaucoup à faire et et on le fera lors
du débat sur la loi de santé
publique au printemps 2015 il y a
certainement beaucoup d'AM à faire en
général pour faire des économies
pourquoi est-ce que celui est-ce que
c'est celui-là précisément vous avez
déposé et pas et pas d'autres alors
parce que encore une fois vous donnez
comme cible à une opinion publique qui
est aujourd'hui inquiète qui est
angoissé par une situation économique
sociale évidemment qui les qui les
inquiète vous leur donnez comme piste
une fausse solution une fausse solution
qui est de rendre ces personnes
responsables du déficit de l'assurance
maladie et encore une fois oui c'est la
une position du Sénat ça n'est pas rien
moi j'appelle les collègues à à rester
un peu dans la tradition une certaine
tradition humaniste de cette assemblée
et à faire attention on ne peut pas
faire abstraction du contexte dans
lequel on est aujourd'hui nous savons
très bien comment si le Sénat adopte des
amendements de ce type comment d'autres
vont les utiliser et et ça c'est ça qui
est dangereux et et je m'adresse à vous
chers collègues pour vous vous demander
sur ce point d'être responsable de
mesurer votre responsabilité à lancer le
débat public sur cette question et
uniquement sur cette question
aujourd'hui on a une mission santé on
pourrait s'intéresser à beaucoup de
sujets et comme par hasard c'est ce cet
amement là que vous déposez donc je je
fais appel à votre responsabilité je
vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Laurence
Cohen
oui Mo je pense que ce débat du coup est
tronqué pourquoi parce que on est là
regardez dans dans la Haute Assemblée on
est en train de de voir d'examiner des
missions qui sont extrêmement
importantes pour la santé de nos
concitoyennes et de nos concitoyens son
ça se passe un samedi après-midi on peut
pas dire qu'on soit très très nombreux
et on est en train de se polariser sur
une question qui n'est pas une question
essentielle en terme de budget de de la
santé
alors si vous dites moi j'écoute les
orateurs et j'ai écouté le rapporteur
j'ai entendu c'est un amendement d'appel
pour que ce débat ait lieu et pour
qu'éventuellement il y ait des une
mission qu'il y ait quelque chose qui
soit mis en route ça je peux l'entendre
je veux dire que pourquoi ne pas
effectivement au niveau de notre haute
assemblée
organiser un travail sur cette question
et cetera en ayant les éléments pourquoi
je dis dit ça parce que on a
l'impression que les arguments qu'on se
qu'on se donne les uns et les autres
c'est comme si on était assez sourd au
aux arguments des banques qui ne sont
pas les nôtres moi j'ai regardé le le le
rapport de Ligas le rapport de Ligas va
à l'encontre de ce que ce qui est dit
sur les bancs de de l'UMP je fais
confiance à l'IGAS qui dit non il y a
pas explosion du nombre de demandeurs de
c'est pas comme ça que les que les
chiffres apparaissent donc est-ce que le
rapport de de Ligas est juste ou pas
est-ce qu'il faut travailler sur cette
questionl au sein d'une mission pourquoi
pas mais pas à l'Ô à l'ône d'un rapport
parce que à l'ône d'un amendement
excusez-moi pourquoi parce que
l'amendement qui nous est proposé dit il
faut recentrer si j'ai bien compris
monsieur le rapporteur il faut recentrer
sur disons les missions essentielles et
par exemple sur l'accès aux femmes
enceintes et aux mineurs bon voilà ce
qui est donné en disant je ne veux pas
supprimer mais moi je regarde encore au
niveau des rapports qui qui nous ont été
communiqués par l'IGAS 80 % des
bénéficiaires sont des hommes et ne
serait donc pas du tout impacté par ce
qui est visé sur l'amendement donc la
réponse qui est apporté par l'amendement
est une mauvaise réponse donc ça n'est
pas cette réponse là qu'il faut faire
après je je partage complètement ce que
mes collègues ont dit quand ils disent
que attention au risque que nous allons
prendre sur la santé publique parce que
effectivement nous sommes tous porteurs
de microbes de virus et cetera mais sur
les position les populations les plus
fragiles on va atteindre des euh comment
dire des risques qui sont beaucoup plus
importants donc là encore le le
l'amendement qui nous est proposé n'est
pas un amendement qui répond à la
problématique donc je veux dire que on
est en qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire dans notre
hémicycle on veut répondre à une
question de santé publique à à l'ône
d'un amendement qui va passer qui va
entraîner un débat sur un contexte
politique qui est pipé et qui est nosé à
bon alors j'entends le j'entends
monsieur le rapporteur dire mais vous
savez et opposer les populations entre
ceux qui seraient bénéficiaaires de la
de la me et ceux qui seraient
bénéficiaires de la CMUC mais monsieur
le rapporteur votre amendement même s'il
passe mais il va pas en donner plus au
bénéficiaaires du de de la CMUC donc
c'est pas une c'est pas une mesure de
justice sociale que vous vous proposez
donc sur les si on reprend puisque moi
je je je je tiens compte des arguments
que vous donnez pour voir quelle est la
nature de votre amendement sur les
questions auxquelles votre amendement
est censé répondre il ne répond pas donc
il n'est pas utile à mon sens de le
maintenir et pour des raisons
d'efficacité par rapport au problèmes
que vous vous poser mais pour des
questions aussi effectivement de justice
sociale et de respect de l'ensemble des
populations parmi les plus fragiles qui
sont déjà suffisamment stigmatisés je
pense que cet amendement est mal venu et
donc il vaudrait mieux euh souhaiter
qu'il y ait un rapport de travail une
mission et cetera issu de notre haute
assemblée plutôt que de d'essayer de
passer par un amendement qui de toute
façon aura une vie très courte la parole
est à Monsieur Paul
Savari merci Monsieur le merci monsieur
le Président il est pas question à
travers de cet amendement de stigmatiser
qui que ce soit
ni ni stigmatiser ceux qui en sont
bénéficiaire des étrangers en situation
irrégulière résidant de plus de 3 mois
en France je vous rappelle 93 % de la
dépense est liée à cela ni de
stigmatiser l'action des médecins ou des
hôpitaux que l'on dénonce si un médecin
ou un hôpital refuse des patients parce
qu'il n'a pas les moyens d'être soigné
on est dans ce pays-là on n'est pas dans
ce pays-là sinon nous serions les
premiers à le dénoncer moi je seraai le
premier à dénoncer un confrère qui
refuserait de soigner quelqu'un mettant
en danger cette personne et son
entourage parce que il n'a pas les
moyens de se soigner je crois que le
débat n'est pas là donc soyons
raisonnable mais il y a un vrai problème
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
marquer à travers le
PLF la difficulté rencontrée dans
l'ensemble des quartiers nos concitoyens
ne comprennent plus cette politique on
peut pas demander des efforts aux uns et
pas les demander aux autres comment leur
expliquer que qu lorsqu'on est français
ou étranger en situation
régulière on est soumis en ce qui
concerne les soins
un nom
d'âme qui limite la progression des
dépenses et lorsqu'on est en situation
irrégulière résidant plus de 3 mois en
France qu faut-il le prouver on n pas de
soumission à une limitation de la
progression des dépenses il y a quelque
chose qui ne va pas moi je ne peux plus
l'expliquer madame c'est un problème où
il faut trouver madame la ministre
pardon c'est un problème où il faut
trouver le juste milieu entre la
politique d'immigration et la politique
sanitaire c'est le même problème que
pour les murs les mineurs étrangers
isolés il faut trouver le juste milieu
entre la politique de de l'immigration
et la prise en charge à travers nos
actions
médicausociales donc il faut faire en
sorte de ne pas attiser les haines de
stigmatiser personne mais de répon à ce
véritable problème car problème il y a
et proposer des solutions ces solutions
on ne prétend pas les amener aujourd'hui
mais on prétend faire en sorte qu'elle
soit prise en compte au niveau du
gouvernement ça me paraît tout à fait
essentiel et cette politique de
l'immigration par rapport aux soins doit
être telle qu'elle ne doit pas favoriser
les filières
d'immigration clandestine comme pour les
mineurs étranger isolé permettez-moi
quelques secondes de vous exposer un
fait récent où j'interrogeais un mineur
étranger
isolés directement qui venait de pays
éloigné plusieurs millions de kilomètres
en camion coout du passage 3000 € et je
lui ai demandé quelle devait être la
destination qui lui avait été donné au
départ c'était l'adresse de mon foyer
départemental de enfance donc j'ai le
sentiment d'organiser cette filière de
d'enfant en difficulté parce que il y a
un système qui permet de vendre une
prestation de livraison de
personnes en difficulté dans notre pays
je ne veux pas être complice de cela
madame je ne veux pas être complice de
cela et à travers nos actions voilà ce à
quoi aboutit notre politique il nous
faut donc l'aborder pour faire en sorte
de trouver la solution et le juste
milieu qui caractérise en général les
définitions que l'on donne au niveau du
Sénat en dans ces politiques qui sont
effectivement difficiles à aborder et
difficile à être comprise par nos
concitoyens et je concluraai simplement
qu'à travers cette proposition on
s'aligne sur ce que font les pays
étrangers et notamment les pays
européens ils ont tous revu leur
politique par rapport à cette ces soins
adressé à nos concitoyens le dernier
pays à avoir modifié dans ce sens-là
l'action qu' en faveur de ceux qui sont
en difficulté chez eux et qui sont
clandestins c'est l'Espagne c'est dans
votre rapport c'est la raison pour
laquelle je soutiens l'amendement
proposé par le sénateur de lâre la
parole est à Madame Françoise
Laborde merci monsieur le Président
juste quelques mots puisque bon monsieur
carucci m'a cité c'est exact j'ai dit en
effet chers collègues qu'il y avait une
augmentation mais j'ai expliqué aussi
que c'était est dû à un certain nombre
de filières comme nous l'a expliqué
madame la ministre et madame la ministre
des Affaires sociales de la santé et des
droits des femmes donc c'était s'est
engagé à lutter contre ces dérives donc
je voulais le préciser puisque bien sûr
nous dans notre groupe nous avons
quelquefois quelques diversité et donc
nous avons déjà engagé un débat et je
dois pouvoir dire que nous persistons à
dire que l'ame est importante
puisqu'elle permet la propagation de
certaines maladies je citerai que la
tuberculose mais il y en a plein
d'autres et donc je pense que nous
devons trouver des moyens à la base de
rompre certaines filières et par contre
de permettre à toutes les personnes qui
sont sur notre territoire qu'elle soit
ame CMU ou ce que vous voulez qu'elle
qu'elle soit soignée pour empêcher la
propagation de
virus merci madame la ministre vous avez
souhaité prendre la parole oui à mot un
mot rapidement pour dire bon vous vous
comprendrez que je suis toujours
défavorable à cet amendement et à ceux
qui suivent sur le même sujet d'ailleurs
euh pour vous dire la chose suivante je
ne suis pas sûre que si vous voulez
résoudre cette question notamment ce que
vous avez dit monsieur le sénateur
Savari euh ce soit sur la base justement
de cet amendement des textes vont arrivé
j'ai évoqué celui sur le droit d'asile
par exemple je pense que c'est ça va
être un texte important et qui peut
contribuer notamment à terme avoir
justement des effets sur différents
domaines qu'on peut-être on ne mesure
pas d'ailleurs tous euh à ce jour et
puis d'autres textes aussi vont nous
permettre de travailler sur sur ces
questions moi par cette prise de parole
je voulais réaffirmer la volonté du
gouvernement déjà de de toute sa
détermination justement à lutter contre
des réseaux ces réseaux mafieux qui
aujourd'hui euh mettent mettent dans des
situations extrêmement et dangereuses et
de précarité extrême des jeunes mineurs
par exemple mais aussi des personnes qui
croient arrivant ici que et bien elles
vont trouver une forme d'Eldorado alors
que elles se retrouvent dans des
difficultés
extrêm mais nous avons le souci aussi de
garder évidemment à l'esprit que ces
personnes en attendant évidemment le
traitement de leurs demandes qui soit en
droit d'asile ou ou autre et bien
qu'elle puisse être respecté le temps
qu'elle passe sur notre sur notre
territoire éviter les appels d'air c'est
toujours c'est toujours évidemment la
question qui est posée dans ce type de
débat c'est pour ça que comme je vous le
disais au début de mes propos il me
semble qu'il faut travailler sur le
sujet à la fois de l'immigration mais
aussi de comment on organise même au
niveau européen parce queon voit ce qui
se passe à Calais et la mre de Calais
qui n'est pas de de ma majorité le dit
elle-même s'il n'y a pas une coopération
réelle sur cette question de
l'immigration et sur la lutte contre les
réseaux qui sont les mêmes d'ailleurs
réseaux de trait humaines et bien nous
nous pourrons faire tous les amendements
tous les ans pour réduire à chaque fois
de 150 millions d'euros cette enveloppe
c'est par ça le sujet le sujet c'est
comment évidemment à terme cette
enveloppe baisse parce que Ben des
personnes en situation irrégulière
seront moins présents parce qu'ils
auront eu une réponse à leur attente ou
qu'ils n'auront pas ils ne seront pas
venus sur le territoire parce que
justement et bien des réseaux qui
organisent parfois ces filières et bien
auront été
maîtrisé je mets au voix l'amendement
j'étis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe UMP sur
l'amendement
68 je rappelle que l'avis du
Gouvernement est défavorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques instants
résultat du scrutin numéro 51 sur
l'amendement 68 nombre de votants 336
nombre de suffffage exprimé 336 pour
l'adoption 185 contre 151 le Sénat a
adopté je suis saisi d'un amendement
numéro 187 c'est Monsieur Magra qui le
défend merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues notre collègue Lao
faolou retenu à Wallis par la session de
l'Assemblée territoriale m'a demandé de
présenter cet amendement dont l'enjeu
est très important pour Wallis et Futuna
mais aussi pour la Nouvelle-Calédonie et
surtout pour les relations entre les
deux territoires la santé à wali et
Futuna est une compétence de l'État
alors qu'elle est une compétence
territoriale en
Nouvelle-Calédonie du fait du manque
d'équipe éip médicaux et du peu de
spécialistes dispensés à Wallis et
Futuna les habitants sont souvent
évacués sanitair vers la Nouvelle
Calédonie doté de budget insuffisant
l'agence de santé de wice et Futuna a
accumulé à l'égard de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie une dette qui
avoisine les 20 millions
d'euros ce phénomène s'est déjà produit
dans le passé mais l'État avait toujours
apurer sa dette avec rapidité le
président de la République et le
gouvernement en à plusieurs reprises
depuis 1 an et demi réaffirmer que cette
dette était bien la dette de l'État et
que l'État rembourserait la
Nouvelle-Calédonie cependant rien n'a
encore été fait et la tension
communautaire devienne très vive en
Nouvelle-Calédonie où certains dans la
population accuse les walisiens et
futuniens d'être responsable de
l'insuffisante offre de soins proposée
au néocalédonien des heures et des
manifestations ont déjà eu lieu à Nea à
un moment même les accé de sanitaé à de
walis et Futuna ont été refusé à
l'hôpital de numea ce qui a entraîné
faut-il leur raeler un décès il n'est
pas normal que l'État ne rembourse pas
ses dettes à l'égard de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie il n'est pas
davantage normal que les habitants de
Wallis et Futuna qui sont pleinement
français et nombreux sous les drapeaux
comme l'a rappelé le président de la
République lui-même ne soi même pas
aussi bien traité je dis bien aussi bien
traité et soigné que les étrangers en
situation irrégulière
le rebasage du budget de l'Agence de
santé de wice et Futuna doit donc servir
à éviter la reconstitution d'une
nouvelle dette et à faire des
investissements par exemple je crois
qu'il souhait se doter d'un scanner
visant à réduire les evassanes et ne
saurait en aucun cas servir au
remboursement de la dette actuelle c'est
pourquoi cet amendement afin de calmer
les tensions communautaires en
Nouvelle-Calédonie afin d'éviter la
survenue d'événements qui pourrait être
dramatique propose simplement de prendre
2000 million d'euros sur la dotation de
laame pour qu'il soit versé à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie en un geste de début
rapide d'appurement de la dette de
l'État je rappelle madame la ministre
que vous venez de nous dire que le
montant total de laame était de
678 ce que demandent les Wallisiens
c'est 2 millions non pas de diminuer de
2 millions mais d'affecter 2 millions
pour régler un problème qui peut
s'avérer délicat entre deux
collectivités
monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la commission des
Finances n'a pas eu l'opportunité de
regarder cet amendement mais il se
trouve que nous sommes deux ici à avoir
au moins été à W et Funa une fois et on
sait très bien que le problème de santé
est un vrai problème ils attendent
d'ailleurs toujours leur premier
scanner donc ils sont en réalité pas mal
dépendants pour dès lors que les choses
prennent un peu de gravité de leur
soutien logistique qui est la Nouvelle
Calédonie et principalement l'hôpital de
nè donc ce ils en sont au stade d'après
ce que m'a dit notre collègue sénateur
que j'ai pu
entretenir ils en sont au stade d'un
conflit et l'hôpital refuse parfois et
même assez souvent maintenant des
malades de WIS et Futuna qui arrivent
pour se faire soigner donc il faut
absolument donner un signe donc il y a
20 millions de de dettes mais le signe
de 2 millions il me semble madame la
ministre dans votre sagesse et peut-être
madame la présidente de la commission
des finances qu'il serait bon que nous
votions cet amendement parce que
franchement c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas de c'est pas du luxe euh W et Futuna
il y a pas un réseau il y a pas ils sont
vraiment dépendants de pour tout alors
bah oui alors s'ils arrivent à Néa on
les refuse c'est quand même
problématique franchement alors eux ils
ont enfin bref je pense que ça serait de
ça serait de bonne politique de leur
donner les 2 millions pour permettre de
d'atténuer les conflits hein parce que
ils ont son niveau conflictuel ça cause
unre de trouble et notre collègue
sénateur là-bas d'illeurs il est pas en
science que il essaie de calmer un peu
et et en prime vous savez qu'ils ont
trois rois deux à Futuna et un et wice
vous avez rencontré un moi j'ai
rencontré les trois bon quand ils vous
disent qu'ils sont un peu débordés par
les problèmes c'est vrai donc il faut
pas s'attendre à ce que ça ser r
facilement donc la commission Nea pas
examiné mais à titre
personnel je je suis favorable à cet
amendement avis du gouvernement madame
la
ministre
monsieur le rapporteur vous n'êtes pas
le seul à connaître un peu Alice et la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et et je voudrais
apporter justement donc une réponse
précise à la question qui est posée par
cet amendement vous proposez d'augmenter
de 2 million d'euros la subvention de
l'agence de santé de waliss Futuna afin
qu'elle commence à App purer sa dette
vis-à-vis du centre hospitaler
territorial de Nouvelle-Calédonie le
Gouvernement partage évidemment votre
préoccupation et plusieurs mesures ont
été décidées afin de régler cette
situation premièrement le gouvernement a
prévu en PLFR 2014 un abondement de 3
millions d'euros de la dotation de
l'agence afin de ne pas créer de
nouvelles dettes en
2014 deuxièmement en 2015 cet effort
sera poursuivi la dotation qui est
versée à l'Agence de Santé a été
revalorisée de 2,5 million d'euros
passant de 26 million d'euros à en LFI
2014 à 28,5 million d'euros en PLF 2015
cette hausse de la dotation de l'agence
de santé de walis et Futuna doit à
nouveau permettre d'éviter de constituer
de nouvelles dettes en 2015 en
améliorant le fonctionnement de l'agence
troisièmement le président de la
République lors de son voyage en
nouvelle calonie le 19 novembre dernier
a annoncé qu'une solution avait été
trouvée pour l'extinction définitive de
cette dette il n'apparaît donc plus
justifié de relever la subvention à
l'agence de santé les mesures nécesses
ayant été prise par le gouvernement pour
apurer cette dette au bénéfice de ces
explications je vous demande de retirer
votre amendement
merci est-ce que l'amendement est
maintenu monsieur magr
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues j'entends bien
l'explication qui est donnée par la
ministre et je crois que mon collègue de
nouvelle de W et founa l'entendra aussi
bien néanmoins la mise en place du
dispositif que vous proposez n'est pas
encore effective et risque de prendre du
temps plus de temps qu'annoncé depuis un
an et demi les engagements ont été pris
et répétés mais n'ont jamais été suivi
d' faets concret et immédiat donc un
geste doit être fait aujourd'hui sous
peine de risquer une situation que la
situation ne dégénère nos collègues du
Pacifique sont inquiets l'amendement est
raisonnable il ne propose qu'un geste
d'apaisement 10 % de la dette simplement
et moins de 0,3 % du budget de la me à
sacré il ne fait pas obstacle à la mise
en place du système que vous proposez
pour les 18 millions d'euros restants
mais vous avez vous-même dit madame la
ministre que l'essentiel des
augmentations que vous prévoyez au
budget de l'agence sont destiné à ne pas
créer de nouvelles dettes c'est-à-dire
que nous sommes dans deux problématiques
parallèles l'une qui consiste à donner à
walis et Futuna les moyens de ne pas
créer de nouvelles dettes une autre
démarche qui consiste à appurer une
dette qui après tout n'est pas celle de
Wallis et Futuna mais bien celle de
l'État parce que notre collègue a tenu à
rappeler qu'à wali Futuna la santé n'est
pas une compétence territoriale mais
bien une compétence d'État ce qui n'est
pas le cas à Nouvelle-Calédonie où il
faut aussi se mettre à la place du
territoire de Nouvelle-Calédonie
lorsqu'un hôpital a un trou de 20
millions d'euros dans son budget il faut
qu'il trouve des solutions et c'est une
compétence territoriale donc dans
l'immédiat moi je souhaite maintenir
l'amendement de mon collègue et je pense
mes chers collègues que nous pourrions
faire ce
à l'égard de nos amis de walis et Futuna
et de Nouvelle-Calédonie la parole est à
Madame Laurence Cohen pour explication
de
vote oui moi moi je je je trouve que
voilà là on a on a un amendement qui va
dans le le même sens que celui qui nous
a été pr présenté avant par monsieur le
rapporteur qui a été maintenu malgré les
interventions qu'on a pu faire les uns
et les autres c'est-à-dire c'est la
porte ouverte à l'opposition entre entre
des catégories différentes de de patient
et on va opposer et on va on va se faire
on va vraiment faire en mettre en
concurrence ceux qui ont laame ceux qui
ont la CMU et on va piocher les 2
millions là d'économie sur laame parce
que après tout est-ce que vraiment il la
mérite et on va mais c'est quoi cette
politique là c'est une politique
d'opposition c'est une politique de
ségrégation et je trouve qu'elle est
extrêmement dangereuse alors ce qui
m'étonne beaucoup nous au niveau du
groupe communiste républicain et citoyen
depuis début et Madame la Ministre peut
en être le témoin on trouve que la voie
qui a été choisie pour le le le PLFSS et
là sur les différentes missions c'est la
même chose c'est une voie où on réduit
les budgets on fait des économies et où
il y a une volonté gouvernementale que
nous ne partageons pas puisque nous nous
sommes sur d'autres financements nous
l'avons nous avons fait des propositions
par voie d'amendement qui ont été rejeté
qui ont été rejetés d'ailleurs sur
différents bancs et vous monsieur le
sénateur qui présentz cet amendement là
en disant mais on manque d'argent vous
auriez pu peut-être y penser plutôt et
réfléchir à d'autres façons de financer
notre système de protection sociale et
de santé on ne peut pas dire qu'il y a
un manque d'argent au niveau de la santé
de la protection sociale et ne pas
arrêter de continuer sur une politique
d'économie là il y a une une vraie
contradiction et alors la contradiction
elle est poussée à son paroxisme quand
finalement et bien vous préconisez une
santé à plusieurs à plusieurs vitesses
et il va y avoir une santé des pauvres
des plus pauvres et des nantis et ça ça
ne va pas dans un système démocratique
et et dans un système de protection
sociale où il doit y avoir une autre
orientation c'est-à-dire celle des
besoins humains donc cet amendement va
vraiment à l'encontre des principes que
l'on peut défendre et je trouve qu'il va
tout à fait dans la logique de
l'amendement précédent qui nous a été
proposé c'est vraiment la la porte
ouverte à un climat qui est
particulièrement nosé à bon la parole
est à Madame Génisson pour explication
de vote
oui merci monsieur le Président le
l'objet le le sujet qu'évoque
l'amendement est un vrai sujet et un
sujet comment dire tout à fait légitime
et madame la ministre a parfaitement
répondu à l'objet de votre amendement et
j'ai envie de dire que par rapport à
l'objet de votre amendement il pourrait
être complètement retiré mais je dirais
simplement que la façon dont vous voulez
résoudre les problèmes de financement de
la santé à Wallis et Futuna est
totalement inadmissible c'est spécifi
iquement sur les crédits ame que l'on
veut reprendre de l'argent pour la
donner pour les donner à walis et Futuna
il y a des misères plus indigne que
d'autres ou des misères moins indignes
que d'autres c'est vraiment un débat qui
qui qui pour le coup est assez
inadmissible est assez inacceptable
alors d'abord madame la ministre vous a
répondu donc le sujet n'existe plus et
deuxièmement franchement alors que nous
devrions avoir un débat serein sur cette
question là nous avons tenté de le tenir
nous avons dit que l'aide médicale
d'État était une vraie question nous
avons sollicité les uns et les autres la
nécessité de la poursuite d'une
réflexion de la possibilité
d'élaboration d'un rapport et là nous
sombrons vraiment dans l'inacceptable la
vie du gouvernement madame la Présidente
vous avez la parole oui monsieur le
Président une fois n'est pas coutum mais
il n'est pas de tradition que la
présidente de la commission des finances
ou le président d'ailleurs euh reprenne
sur le fond mais j'ai la chance d'avoir
moi-même il y a bien longtemps euh fait
le voyage à walis et Futuna et et et vu
la difficulté de problèmes de santé
encore plus à Futuna mais à Wallis
également et madame la ministre nous a
dit elle-même ce qu'elle connaît
également d'une situation difficile je
pense que si cet amendement avait été
examiné à la Commission des finance mon
cher collègue et avec les documentation
et compris la la position de notre
rapporteur ici sur ce sujet je pense que
nous aurions invité au retrait tout
simplement parce que si et moi j'ai
confiance et je pense qu'il faut que
vous entriez dans cette confiance je
sais que c'est pas votre amendement
c'est celui de notre collègue mais tout
de même faites faites-lui je pense cette
grâce il l'aurait prié
ainsi l'inscription au PLFR sur cette
problématique qui est bien réelle moi
j'ai vu effectivement la façon dont
parfois les
Calédoniens vivent mal l'arrivée des
walisiens nous le nous le voyons nous
l'avons vu et c'est un sujet difficile
mais je pense que insption au PLFR mon
cher collègue je pense qu'il faut que
que vous intégriez l'idée que un retrait
c'est dans quelques jour le PLFR nous
allons l'aborder nous allons commencer
nous faites
confiance Madame le Ministre
oui ce que je voulais
dire rapidement c'est que si il y a eu
cet engagement du Président de la
République il y a quelques jours à peine
à nous na c'est qu'il y a évidemment
vous pouvez vous pouvez en convenir un
engagement très fort et que le sujet en
disant que le sujet n'existait plus
c'est que la solution a été trouvée donc
euh je c'est pour ça que je vous demande
le retrait parce que je ne voudrais pas
euh pour diverses raisons d'ailleurs
voilà dire qu'il faut euh que je suis
défavorable à votre amendement même si
les compensations que vous vous
présentez sont discutables mais je
préfère m'attacher au fond du sujet
monsieur magr oui merci monsieur le
Président la ministre chers
collègu j'entends bien tout ce qui est
dit je regrette que notre collègue
madame Cohen je pense qu'elle vous
n'avez pas bien compris le sens de ma
démarche je pense pas qu'il s'inscrivve
dans le sens de l'amendement précédent
c'est différent c'est une collectivité
qui est c'est l'État qui s'est endetté
et l'État a une grosse dette vis-à-vis
d'une collectivité qu' le met en
difficulté ceci étant j'entends la vol
volonté de l'État
de de régler le problème cet amendement
il il alerte sur l'urgence il il y a un
hôpital anumea qui a un 20 millions de
dettes dis donc que l'État français a 20
millions de dettes envers cet hôpital
bon né enmins moi en défendant
laamendement de mon collègue je pensais
obtenir de la part de mes collègues et
de vous-même madame la ministre une
compréhension de la difficulté réelle et
de ce de de l'urgence qu' il y a à
régler je peux penser à travers vos
propos qu'il y a un engagement de votre
part pour que la la pour de la part du
gouvernement pour que la solution soit
trouvée je sais très bien parce que si
je maintiens l'amendement si on va un
scrutin public et si on fait passer
l'amendement sa durée de vie sera
terminée dans quelques jours à
l'Assemblée nationale donc pour toutes
ces raisons je pense que le débat est
intéressant je crois que vous avez tous
pris conscience quand même qu'il y a un
vrai problème là-bas il n'y a pas de
pauvre et de riche il y a simplement une
réalité c'est que tout le monde doit
être soigné et
que l'État doit assumer ses
responsabilités en matière de santé mais
je vais donc retirer l'amendement
puisque son sort est à peu près
connu merci mon cher collègue
l'amendement est retiré nous allons
procéder au vote des crédits de la
mission santé figurant à l'état B je
mets au voix les crédits de la mission
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe UMP sur les crédits
de la mission santé inscrit à l'état il
va être procédé au scrutin public dans
les conditions fixées par l'article 56
du règlement le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques
instants résultat du scrutin numéro 52
sur l'ensemble des crédits de la mission
santé nombre de votants 335 nombre de
suffrag exprimés 335 pour l'adoption 184
contre 151 le Sénat a adopté j'appelle
en discussion l'article 59 amendement
qui est rattaché pour son examen au
crédit de la mission
santé à l'article 59 je suis saisi d'un
amendement numéro 69 présenté par
Monsieur delâre au nom de la commission
des finances amendement rédactionnel
monsieur le Président avis du
gouvernement favorable merci madame la
ministre je mets au voix j'imagine que
il est
adopté je vous en remercie je mets au
voix l'article 59 sexè même vote
non vote alors qui est
pour c'est surutre non non l'article
addictionnel est après article 59 donc
je mets au voix je mets au voix
l'article qui est
pour qui est contre
abstention il est adopté j'appelle en
discussion l'amendement tendant à
insérer un article additionnel qui est
rattaché pour son examen au crédit de la
mission
santé merci monsieur le Président bien
écoutez c'est dans la droite ligne de ce
que l'on a déjà
évoquéin et donc il revenit au
rapporteur pour avis de la mission santé
de la commission des affaires sociales
de présenter cet amendement qui a été
adopté par la commission afin de
responsabiliser les patients dans leur
recours au système de soin la loi du 3
août 2004 relative à l'assurance maladie
instaure à son article 20 une
contribution forfaitaire sur les actes
médicaux et les actes de biologieque
dont le plafond annuel est fixé à 50 €
donc le présent amendement tant
instituer une participation comparable
pour les bénéficiire de l'aide médicale
de l'état le montant de la participation
est identique au au plafond de la
participation forfaitaire de trois
commun en vigueur depuis le 1er Janier
2005 soit 50
€ la commission monsieur le
rapporteur la commission des Finances
n'a pas examiné cet amendement monsieur
le Président à titre personnel je donne
vie personnel favorable et je crois que
c'est aussi un amendement de la
commission des affaires sociales j'ai
bien compris donc la commission des
finances en général sur ce genre de
voilà on donne VI titre
personnel merci monsieur le rapporteur
avis du gouvernement madame la ministre
défavorable je mets au voix l'amendement
qui est pour ah pardon je suis saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe UMP sur l'amendement
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques
instants scutin est
ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invite les
secrétaires à procéder au dépouillement
du
scrutin
résultat du scrutin numéro 53 sur
l'amendement nombre de votants 336
nombre de suffrag exprimés 336 pour
l'adoption 185 contre 151 le Sénat a
adopté voilà vous avez donc suivre la
suite de l'examen du projet de loi de
financeces avec le Sénat qui a réduit
samedi dernier les crédits pour l'aide
médicale d'État on y revient bien sûr
dans un instant dans 24h Sénat présenté
par Delphine
Gérard